This is Jocko podcast number 83 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening
on the 19th of February,
1945 after three days of heavy pre landing bombardment,
which attempted to destroy the heavy fortifications that the Japanese had built
on that day.
The 19th of February,
1945 in American amphibious forces,
primarily US marines of the third or fourth and fifth marine divisions along
with soldiers from the US army's 140 seventh infantry regiment landed on the
island of [inaudible].
By the end of the first day,
some battalions had a casualty rate of over 80%
yeah.
On the morning of 20 February,
1945 Marine Corps First Lieutenant Isaacs was taking cover and a foxhole about
300 yards from the beach.
When he was hit by a Japanese mortar strike,
he was severely wounded in his left arm and in his head
he was evacuated to a hospital ship off shore,
which is where he died the next day on February 21st,
and it was about two months prior to that on December 17th,
1945 that First Lieutenant Leonard Smith Isaacs had written a letter.
Yeah,
to his two boys.
Now
I have a lot of people ask me questions about parenting.
I got four kids,
so,
so people want to know my thoughts on it be.
We'll also obviously ask me about war and they asked me what kind of advice I
have for my son.
And I think that First Lieutenant Isaac's answers many
of these questions a lot better than I ever could.
No.
And here's what he told them in that letter.
Okay.
December 17th,
1944 my dear little boys,
I'm writing you today,
just a week before Christmas Eve in in the that you will get this little note at
Christmas time.
Yeah.
All of this coming week.
We'll be holidays and I can just imagine the fun you'll be having,
especially when you know it's just a few days before Santa Claus will be coming.
Yeah.
If it were possible,
I would like to come down the chimney myself and crawl right into your stocking.
Wouldn't that be a surprise?
Okay.
I would enjoy it even more than you.
But since your dad is far away and Santa Claus has the only rain deers that
we'll fly through here,
I'm afraid we'll have to let Santa Claus used them
after all.
He has so many places to go in such a short time.
I won't be able to give you a Christmas present personally this year,
but I do want you to know that I think of you all the time and feel very proud
of the way you have been helping your mother while I'm gone.
I know that it's only natural for young,
healthy and strong boys like you are to want to play and have fun all the time,
but I do want you to think about helping mummy because it is hard for her to do
everything while I'm gone.
I know that you would like to give me a Christmas present too,
so I will tell you what you can do and this will be your Christmas present to me
every day.
Ask Mommy if there are errands that you can do for her and when there are
errands to run,
say sure mommy,
and then give her a big smile.
Then during the day,
go up to your room and look around.
If there are toys scattered all around,
are you left some of your clothes on the floor?
Pick them up.
Also,
when Mommy is busy trying to clean up the house,
don't leave her by herself,
but ask mummy if you can help her.
Take care of baby sister.
Yeah.
If you do those things for me,
that will be the finest Christmas present that you could give me.
Oh yes and CC.
Are you eating your meals like a real man now?
Well,
my boys,
I guess you often wonder why people fight and have wars and why lots of daddy's
have to be oh way.
This Christmas time at fighting
when it would be much nicer to be at home.
Yeah,
that's a hard question to answer,
but you see some countries like Japan and Germany have people living in them
just like people.
You and I know.
Yeah.
Those people want to tell everybody what they can do and what they can't do.
No one likes to be told how to live their life.
I know that you wouldn't like it if one of the boys in the neighborhood tried to
tell you what church you should go to,
what school you should go to,
and particularly if that boy would always be trying to beat up some smaller or
weaker boy,
you wouldn't like it.
What'd you,
and unfortunately,
the only way to make a person like that stop these sort of things or a country
like Japan or Germany,
he has to fight them and beat them and teach them that being a bully because
after all,
that's what they are,
is not the way to live and that we won't put up with it.
What does all this mean to you?
Just simply this,
my boys' Dad doesn't ever want you to be a bully.
I want you to always fight against anyone who tries to be one.
I want you to always help the smaller fellow or the little boy who may not be as
strong as you.
I want you to always share what you have with the other fellow and above all my
boys have courage.
Have courage to do the things that you think are right.
Never be afraid to fight for what you think is right
to do those things.
You need a strong body and a brave heart.
Never run away from someone you may be afraid of.
If you do,
you will feel ashamed of yourself and before long you will find it so easy to
run away from the things that you should stand up and fight against.
If you had lots of other boys,
try to do the things that dad has been talking about in this letter,
they may be that people will not have to fight wars in the years to come.
Okay?
And then all the daddies in this world will be home for Christmas
and that is where they belong.
Perhaps some of the things that I've been talking about you don't quite
understand.
If you don't,
mummy will explain them to you.
She knows
merry Christmas and a happy new year.
God bless you
Daddy,
and obviously
many brave American stood and fought for what they believed in on that
tiny island of Iwo Jima.
Okay.
Then they suffered massive losses to gain that victory
over the course of that five week battle,
19,217 were wounded.
Six 821
were killed.
Okay,
and First Lieutenant Leonard Smith,
Isaacs Marine.
How's it been?
Father
Daddy.
Okay.
Was buried at sea.
34 years old.
Reading that
letter made me think about another letter I had read from another parent
and it's another letter that I find to be
just an incredible guide to not only to parenting,
but to living
on.
This one was written not by a father,
but by a mother and it's not a letter to his son,
but to a daughter.
Then the daughter's name was Janna.
Then the mother's name was Dr Miao,
Alda Horror Kova,
and she wrote the letter from prison
while she was on trial for treason and for conspiracy on trial by the Soviet
backed communist government of Czechoslovakia.
After they had taken control of the country in a coup,
and she and her fellow so called conspirators were jailed and tortured and then
put through a grandiose show trial
and she knew,
she knew that she was going to be made an example of
she knew
she was facing death
planned the night before her execution.
She wrote a letter to her daughter
who was 16 at the time,
and this is some of what wrote
my only little girl,
Janna.
Yeah.
God blessed my life as a woman with you
as your father wrote in the poem from German prison,
God gave you to us because he loved us.
Yeah.
Apart from your father's magic,
amazing love.
You were the greatest gift I received from fate.
Okay.
However,
providence plan my life in such a way that I could not give you nearly all that
my mind and heart had prepared for you.
The reason was not that I loved you little.
I love you just as purely and fervently as all their mothers love their
children.
But I understood that my task here in the world,
what's to do you good by seeing to it that life becomes better
and that all children can live well
and therefore we often had to be apart for a long time.
It is now already for the second time that fate has torn us apart.
Don't be frightened and sad because I am not coming back anymore.
Learn my child to look at life early as a serious matter
life is hard,
okay?
It does not pamper anybody and for every time it's strokes you,
it gives you 10 blows.
Okay?
Become accustomed to that soon,
but don't let it defeat you.
Decide to fight.
Yeah.
Have courage and clear goals and you will win over life.
March is still unclear to your young mind and I don't have time left to explain
to you things I w you would still like to ask me.
Okay?
One day when you grow up,
you will wonder and wonder why your mother,
who loved you and whose greatest gift you were managed her life so strangely.
Perhaps then you will find the right solution to this problem.
Perhaps a better one than I could give you today myself.
Yeah,
of course.
You will not only be able to solve the correctly and truthfully by knowing very,
very much,
not only from books but from people.
Learn from everybody.
No matter how unimportant.
Go through the world with open eyes and listen not only to your own pains and
interests,
but also to the pains,
and longings of others.
Don't ever think of anything as none of your business.
No.
Everything must interest you.
Then use your reflect about everything.
Compare and compose individual phenomenon.
Man Doesn't live in the world alone
in that
there is great happiness,
but also a tremendous responsibility.
That obligation is first of all and not being an acting exclusive,
but rather merging with the needs and the goals of others.
Okay.
This does not mean to be lost in the multitude,
but it is to know that I am part of all and to bring one's best into that
community.
If you do that,
you will succeed in contributing to the common goals of human society.
Be More aware of one principal than I have been.
Approach everything in life constructively.
Be Aware,
be aware of unnecessary negation.
I'm not saying all negation because I believe that one should resist evil,
but in order to be a truly positive person in all circumstances,
one has to learn how to distinguish real gold from tinsel.
It is hard because tensile sometimes glitters,
so dazzlingly
I can fess my child that often in my life I was dazzled by glitter
and sometimes it even shown so falsely that one dropped pure gold from one's
hand and reached for ran after false gold.
You know that to organize one scales of values means to know not only one self
well,
but to be in from an in the analysis of one's character,
but also to know others to know as much as possible of the world it's past,
it's present
and future.
In short,
to understand
not to close one's ears before anything and for no reason,
not even to shut out the faults and opinions of anybody who stepped on my toes
or even wounded me deeply.
Examine,
think,
criticize.
Yes,
mainly criticize yourself.
Don't be ashamed to admit a truth you have come to realize,
even though you proclaim the opposite a little while ago,
okay?
Don't become obstinate about your opinions,
but when you come to consider something right than be so definite that you can
fight and die for it.
That's Walker said,
death is not bad.
Just avoid gradual dying,
which is what happens when one suddenly finds oneself apart from the real life
of others.
You have to put down your roots where fate has determined you for you to live,
you have to find your own way.
Look for it independently.
Don't let anything turn you away from it,
not even the memory of your mother and father,
okay?
If you really love them,
you won't hurt them by seeing them critically,
okay?
Just don't go on a road which is wrong,
dishonest,
and does not harmonize with wife.
I have changed my mind many times,
rearranged many values,
but what was left in as an as an essential value without which I cannot imagine
my life is the freedom of my conscience.
I would like you,
my little girl to think about whether I was right.
Okay,
another value is worth.
Okay?
I don't know which to assign the first place in which the second learn to love
work any work,
but one you have to really to know really and thoroughly then don't be afraid of
anything and things will turn out well for you.
And don't forget about love in your life.
I'm not only thinking of the red blossom,
which one day will bloom in your heart and you.
If fate favors,
you will find a similar one in the heart of another person with WHO's road
yours.
We'll merge.
I'm thinking of love without which one cannot live happily.
I don't ever crumble.
Love,
learn to give it whole and really
and learn to love precisely those who encouraged love so little,
my little girl Janna,
when you will be choosing for whom your maiden heart shall burn and to whom to
really give yourself remember your father.
Okay.
I know if you will meet
with such luck as I,
I don't know if you will meet such a beautiful human being or choose your ideal
close to him.
Perhaps you my little one have already begun to understand and now perhaps you
understand to the point of pain what we have lost in him.
Yeah.
What I find hardest to bear is that I am also guilty of that loss.
I've heard from my legal representative that you are doing well in school and
that you want to continue.
I was very pleased but even if you would one day have to leave school and work
for your livelihood,
don't stop learning and studying.
Okay.
If you really want to,
you will reach your goal.
Yeah.
I would have liked for you to become a medical doctor.
You remember that?
We talked about it.
Of course you will decide yourself and circumstances will too,
but if you stand one day in the traditional alma mater and carry home from
graduation,
not only your doctor's diploma,
but also the real ability to bring people relief as a doctor,
then my little girl,
your mother will be immensely pleased.
Okay?
But your mother would only be truly happy no matter where you stand,
whether at the operating table,
at the lave,
at your child's cradle,
or at the work table in your household.
If you will do your work skillfully,
honestly,
happily,
and with your whole being,
then you will be successful in it.
Don't be demanding in life,
but have high goals.
They're not exclusive of each other
for what I call demanding are those selfish notions and needs.
Restrict them from yourself.
Realize that in view of the disaster and sorrow which happened to you,
Vira epic,
grandmother and grandfather and many others will try to give you what they have
and what they cannot afford.
You should not only not ask for it.
Yeah,
but learn to be modest.
If you become used to it,
you will not be unhappy because of material things you don't have.
Okay.
You don't know how free one feels.
If one trains oneself and modesty,
how he or she gets a headstart over against the
and by how much one is safer and stronger.
I really tried this out on myself and if you can thus double your strength,
you can set yourself courageous,
high goals,
read much and study languages.
You will thereby broadened your life and multiply its content.
There was a time in my life when I read voraciously and then again times when
work did not permit me to take a single book in my hand apart from professional
literature.
That was a shame.
Here in recent months I've been reading a lot,
even books which probably would not interest me outside,
but it is a big important task to read.
Everything valuable or at least much.
That is
I shall write down for you at the end of this letter what I've read in recent
months.
I'm sure you will think of me when you will be reading it
and now also something for your body.
I am glad that you are engaged in sports.
Just do it systematically.
I think that there should be rhythmic exercises and if you have time,
also some good systematic gymnastics
and those quarter hours every morning.
Believe me finally that it would save you a lot of annoyance about unfavorable
proportions of your waist if you could really do it
is also good for the training of your will and perseverance.
Your photograph showed me your new hairdo.
They looks good,
but it isn't it isn't it a shame to hide your nice forehead and that lady and
the ball gown really.
You look lovely,
but your mother's,
I noticed one fault which may be due to the way you were placed on the
photograph.
Wasn't the neck opening a little deep for your 16 years.
Don't primp.
But whenever possible,
dress carefully and neatly.
Janna,
please take good care of grandfather and grandmother.
They're old hearts now.
Need the most constellation.
Yeah.
Visit them often and let them tell you about your father's and mother's youth so
that you can preserve it in your mind for your children.
In that way an individual becomes a mortal and we shall continue in you and the
others of your blood
and one more thing.
Music.
I believe you will show your gratitude to grandfather for the piano which he
gave you by practicing honestly,
and that you will succeed in what peptic wants so much and accompanying him when
he plays the violin or the viola.
Please do them that favor.
I know that it would mean a lot to him and it would be beautiful
and when you can play well together,
play me the urea from Martha,
my rose,
you bloom alone there on the hillside and then sleep my little prince by Mozart
and then your father's favorite under your window by Chopin.
You'll play it for me,
won't you?
I shall always be listening to you.
Just one more thing.
Choose your friends carefully.
Among other things,
one is also very much determined by the people with whom one associates or
associates.
Therefore choose very carefully,
be careful in everything and listen to the opinions of others about your
girlfriends.
Without being told,
I shall never forget your charming letter today.
I can tell you which you once in the evening pinned to my pillow to apologize
when I caught you for the first time at the gate in the company of a girl and a
boy.
You explained to me at that time why it is necessary to have a gang,
have your gang little girl,
but of good and clean young people
and compete with each other in everything.
Good.
Only please don't confuse young people.
Springtime infatuation with real love.
Do you understand me?
If you don't on Vera will help you explain what I meant
and so my only young daughter,
little girl,
Janna,
new life,
my hope,
my future forgiveness,
live
grasp life with both hands.
Until my last breath,
I shall pray for your happiness,
my dear child,
kiss your hair,
eyes and mouth.
I stroke you
and hold you in my arms.
I shall always be with you.
The next day,
despite
international outcry,
Muladhara horror
was executed,
Craig's Penn crack prison.
Then again,
there's just so much to be
learned
from those letters and as parents,
there's so much for us to teach and I think the thing that
hits me is that these are all things that we know,
okay,
we know them.
We know to take care of our health.
We know to wake up and exercise.
We know we should choose our friends carefully.
We know we should be or our own worst critics
and we know that if we have been wrong about something,
we should simply admit that
and move our minds to what is right and what is correct.
We know we should work hard and help people.
We know the value of freedom
and we know that freedom must be fought for
here.
We know that we should be brave and that that is possible only through a strong
body,
mind and heart,
and we know all those things.
We know though.
No,
teach them,
teach them and live them.
Okay.
Set the right example by living them
because
our children
are watching.
Okay.
They're watching it.
I know.
Actually I think you have to do more than just set the example.
I think you actually have to
to tell them.
I think you actually have to tell them and you think about the power of these
letters,
the power of these words,
but it's also a real challenge with kids,
with your own children.
It's a challenge because there's a whole crazy parental child psychology that's
going on here,
right?
You got the rebellion
or the trying to please you or the competing for attention or the,
I can't do anything good enough.
You've got all these psychological things that are going on with your kids and
it's hard.
It's,
it's can be very hard just to be straight with your kids about stuff.
It can be hard not to micromanage them.
That's one of the hardest things because you know so well all these things that
we just talked about,
you know them and you know that they're the best things for your kids and yet if
you push them too intensely,
they're going to push back or they're going to push it.
They're going to head into different direction because you pushed him there.
But I,
I do think that there's some real value in taking the time to explain what
you've learned,
the mistakes that you've made.
And I think it's key not to so much focus on telling them how to live.
I think this is the key is not so much focused on telling them how to live,
but telling them how you have lived,
the mistakes that you've made and how you try to live
so that maybe they can
learn from some of the mistakes that you've made without
having to learn from life itself,
which
sometimes life is a much more brutal teacher.
In fact,
most of the time.
And if you have to learn from life,
sometimes you don't win
harsh.
Yeah.
Parenting is challenging
part that I've thought think is very important.
The most important maybe is when you said our children are watching.
So you know how remember the old saying,
do what I say not what I do.
That doesn't work.
No.
Cause he tells someone,
hey don't,
don't,
I dunno,
why don't smoke.
Don't,
don't,
don't try cigarettes.
Meanwhile you smoke there can be like,
okay,
don't try cigarettes.
You know,
whatever,
you know,
they're,
they're always white.
Like everyday,
all day,
every day they're watching to see how do I act?
I don't know how to,
I'm a kid.
I don't know how to act.
I don't know what to do in this whole,
you know how like when you walk into a party of someone you don't know and maybe
it's a really nice party or something and maybe it's a different culture or
something like that.
You're looking around,
what do I act?
Are we taking off our shoes right here?
Okay.
And we're taking off our shoes.
Okay,
are we,
are we eating now or are we waiting for prayers on that will,
like,
what do we do?
What do we do?
If you're constantly looking on how to add off kids,
that's their whole life.
How do I act?
I don't know how to act.
So of course you're there the whole time.
You've got things figured it out,
figured out you got a car,
you got a house,
you're providing my food,
you're going to show me how to act.
So you started saying,
hey,
don't smoke.
Meanwhile,
100% of the time you're acting in a way that allows for smoking and be like,
oh,
we're smoking it.
By the way,
it's the same exact thing from a leadership perspective,
the way you act as a leader,
it's not at,
I mean you're not going to have people that are as multiple as a kid is,
but there's no doubt if the way you act as leaders,
the way your team is going to act,
there's no dust.
That's 100% yeah,
and if you act like a clown,
you're team is going to act like clowns.
If you take your job seriously,
your,
your team is going to take your job seriously.
If you're very well balanced in between those two where you,
you take your job seriously,
but you still have a good time.
We were doing it.
Your,
your team is going to follow you with that as well.
I remember when I was a new guy and a seal platoon,
I would be watching those,
my leaders all the time and taking,
you know,
when they didn't do something,
when they didn't hold the line when they were late or didn't bring the right
piece of gear,
it was just,
you just look at them and shake your head.
Now I wanted to perform,
but what that meant other people's like c,
it doesn't matter if we really performed that well.
Look,
the boss doesn't even perform well and so you're setting the example.
Yeah.
Your,
your subordinates are watching.
Everybody's watching this every month
people will be like,
you know,
hey,
I'm the type of person that does this.
You know,
I really,
and everyone knows bad.
No you're not.
We've been watching you the whole time I've known you kind of thing.
So yeah,
especially like the boss to even even,
I mean you get all kinds of different people right.
In a,
in a work environment.
So you,
you're like driven.
It comes from yourself.
You're like really self motivated and stuff.
Pretty much.
Yeah.
Kind of.
So let's say even if you have a bunch of self motivated people,
they're still watching you like,
so if you're like kind of the leader and you're like,
hey,
you know,
we're getting,
we're punctual people.
We get our work done early,
like we're this guy.
And then meanwhile you're coming in late or whatever.
The boss is coming in late and he slacking.
You could tell he's slacking,
he's passing like his job
off,
you know,
on to others in the,
in that kind of stuff.
At the very least they're going to look at you and not have the respect it.
I think you should have as a,
as a boss or whatever,
the very least.
And that's if you have self motivated people.
But otherwise the normal situation,
I man,
I remember feeling that all the time where it's like,
wow,
this,
I'm not going to listen to this gay man man.
It's,
you know what's interesting too is just think about,
and I know we've done all their letters from parents,
especially from parents that are headed for GAF or at least a high probability
of death,
but what would you say to your kids if you knew you were heading there and is it
not worth telling them that at some point while you're alive,
you know,
and,
and you can,
you can say,
hey,
look,
if you know I'm alive to tell you this stuff,
this is what I want you to know again.
Now what's crazy is,
even with that,
you have,
you can't override your kids with act this way.
You can't do that.
You got to approach it.
You got to flank them.
You've got,
I got to flank my kids.
You know,
they're not,
the classic example is my son,
he's good at Jujitsu,
right?
He's been trying to judge it to 10 years.
Right?
He's 14 he's been been training in his whole life.
Right.
But he's,
he's not as good at Jujitsu as I am.
I mean he's just not,
cause he'd been training for 10 I've been training for 20 something new.
So you can beat him.
I can be,
yes,
but,
but check it out.
What's funny is I'm his dad,
so when I tell him,
hey son,
move your hips over here,
dude,
you don't need to do that.
I'm thinking to myself,
you've gotta be kidding me.
You gotta be kidding me.
That is the client.
To me,
that's the ultimate example of your kids are not going to listen to you.
They're programmed,
they're programmed to reject you.
At some point they have to move on,
right?
That's the way the species works.
If they just continue to take from you and they don't reject you at some point
and get away from you,
then you didn't good.
Do a good job as a parent because now they're relying on you.
So,
but that comes a little price.
The price is that rebellion,
right?
The rebellions going to come and it's,
you know,
you can identify it.
You know,
my youngest,
it's so nice.
You know,
you tell her something and she's just got the big eyes and she wants to help and
wants to please and wants to do and,
and understands and I'll tell you something else.
There's another end of the spectrum too.
Cause my oldest daughter,
she went through the rebellion.
She's already through that and she got through it pretty quickly to where she
would like,
look at me.
I'm thinking,
I'm thinking you could see it in her eyes that she's thinking he knows what he's
talking about and I'm going to listen to what he's saying now.
It's probably like a 50% is not.
It's not 100% I'm not just dialing in 100% victory on telling her what to do
because otherwise what's sad about that?
This is what's horrible about that.
If you could get a child to actually do everything that you wanted them to do,
they would dominate in life,
right?
Because you would just say,
okay,
I want you to study hard.
I want you to work out.
I want you to do everything that I'm not doing it because I'm lazy and I fell
short of my own goals.
You'd have them do all that stuff.
They're not going to do it,
so you've got to flank of,
you got to figure out.
He also got to figure out which ones are important,
which ones are really important.
Don't waste your leadership capital on,
you know,
getting your kids to dress a certain way.
Right.
That's one.
Parents will spend all kinds of leadership capital on getting their kids to wear
dress a certain way and the reality is,
you mean obviously you gotta,
you gotta remain,
maintain some standard of decency and cleanliness.
Sure.
That's another lead by example.
Situ.
Yeah,
it is.
It is.
My daughters went through a little phase of wearing the short really short jeans
or not,
not jeans,
but shorts.
Yeah.
I was like,
okay,
cool.
I was walking around one day at my house.
I had like a pair of workout shorts on or whatever.
I just pulled them right up and was just walking around.
How do I look?
Hey,
if we're going to show off,
let's just show it off.
Hey,
I got a little something too.
I do squats.
Check me out.
Big girls collapsed in agony.
Dad,
stop.
That's disgusting.
Yay.
If we're showing off butts,
let's show him off.
I'm over here on the squat,
but squat rack,
let's start it.
Got It.
Flaunt it.
You apparently are finding it.
So let's all fall on it.
Let's go into town.
Who's coming with me?
You can only spend so much leadership capital on getting these minor corrections
made.
What you want to make sure is that they have good morals and values so it can
go,
go out in town.
They know where to draw the line on doing stuff that's good or not good.
You know,
somebody asked me a question on Twitter,
I didn't actually answer it fully,
but you know,
he's like,
hey,
you seem to be real black and white about good or evil,
but I think there's a lot of shades of gray in there.
And,
and I totally agree.
Of course.
I mean there's,
there's massive amounts of shades of gray in good and evil.
And then at some point you get to evil.
Then you go from like,
Hey,
this is bad to evil and you go from,
you know,
hey that's pretty nice too good.
Yeah.
Those,
those are things that exist and you want to keep your kids,
you know,
out of the evil.
Right.
And if you waste all your leadership capital trying to push them from doing okay
to good and doing the best and you're going to wet,
you're going to wear it all out.
In my opinion.
If there's some parents that have done a better job than me,
that's awesome.
Yeah.
And they were able to just to keep their kid 5.0 in every category across the
board for their whole existence,
without the kid turning into a crazy,
you know,
rebel.
Cause that's what happens to some kids that get pushed that hard.
Yeah.
I think that whole,
again,
that whole leading by example,
thieman is lay as long as you're consistent and lead by example,
they can see and all they'll see the benefits play out right in front of their
face.
But man,
these again,
you can't,
you can't be like,
hey,
clean your room.
Meanwhile,
the rest of the house,
including your room is messy and grab clean.
I tell you to clean your room all the time.
You never do.
No.
How's this?
So one of my friends,
uh,
one of my best friends was Scotty Lewis.
He's a cop by the way,
you know,
on the big island.
So this guy would,
he was never my roommate,
but you know,
I go to this hustle at time and he was real like clank clean,
super clean guy.
And he'd get kind of mad,
not mad,
but just uncomfortable when things are dirty,
you know,
so,
he has a roommate or something like that.
And I remember thinking,
Dang,
both Scottie are real sensitive about that whole thing,
you know,
being clean and they're like for real clean,
clean,
a clean,
not a clean freak necessarily,
but almost borderline.
Borderline.
Yes.
So,
um,
and just from knowing them and stuff,
I knew that his parents,
they would like,
you know,
clean his room and stuff like that.
Not all the time or nothing like that.
But they were involved in,
in cleaning and stuff.
So it Kinda went opposite to what I thought,
you know,
how like if your parents tell,
if you got taught to clean your room from young age and you had to do it the
whole time.
Yeah.
I always thought that,
yeah.
That that would carry over when you're out of the house and you go to college,
you go live on your own,
that you cleaned your room all the time.
I thought that that was kind of it.
But I start to hypothesize that that's not it.
This is what it is.
If your parents provide in an environment of extreme cleanliness,
whether you do it or they do it or both or whatever,
but the environment is consistently clean when you leave that environment,
that's will be,
that will be what you're used to interest.
So it'll mess with you if it's not.
And that's,
and sure enough,
we went to the big island,
you know,
cruise with him and uh,
we go to his house and it's like a museum just spotless clean,
not his,
his parent's house.
And I remember thinking like,
yeah,
that my little theory I think is correct.
Like if you're used to it,
his parents help him clean or not.
Yes.
Fully.
So here,
and here's the thing about this,
because you could also get the kid that the parents are neat freaks and the kid
rebels and just becomes a slob.
Yeah.
So and yeah,
maybe and I'm sure there's all kinds of circumstances that may be do that I'm
sure.
But I mean generally speaking,
the environment that you get used to functioning,
there's PE,
there's parents that are slobs that the kids are very neat and orderly cause
they don't like that.
Yeah.
I mean maybe,
and again these are all,
you know,
I'm sure there's so many fat,
I've never encountered that.
Well My,
I think the key is here,
what you can't do is just try and push him like crazy.
You just have to guide them in what is correct and what you have to really show
us,
like the benefits of why it's good to keep things in order.
You know,
if you're going to spend an hour looking for your car keys,
just think of your productivity at that point.
It's nil.
So you've gotta watch out for that.
But yeah,
that was my little hypothesis.
I think it's true though,
because think about it,
like,
think about just the environment of the consistent environment that you kind of,
that someone will come from the always in a way,
sort of,
for lack of a better term,
create,
recreate that environment or try to when they leave.
So like,
you know how like kids would come from a chaotic,
people yell,
they're going to probably yell a lot.
Or let's say they don't yell,
let's say they never swear right there.
Like I grew up in a household and they don't swear and swearing like not that
good when they go out.
They won't just start swearing though.
They'll be sensitive to swearing,
freestyle,
you know?
For sure.
So I think that,
uh,
again,
if,
if the environment is provided consistently,
I think that's,
that's going to have a big consistency goes a long way.
I think it's the number one thing.
Sarah Armstrong always says that I agree with us.
Thousand million.
Christine.
Consistent,
even like small little things like,
uh,
for my daughter for example,
it's the routine is when it's time to go to bed,
it's brushed teeth.
We do stories and questions,
which is like,
just like,
you know,
some stories,
I mean up and then questions like basically a quiz.
It's like rudimentary education,
like solar system stuff and you make it like a game show quiz.
So it's fun.
And then bedtime.
That's it.
Then sleep
hundred percent,
no deviation unless we're out.
But that's how,
that's the routine.
Consistent.
So now you need,
I don't get any pushback and my daughter is a pushback master.
The consistent stuff.
She just knows.
She just go,
you can be playing.
She's,
she's got a little spark to her.
Yeah.
Actually it's got a lot of,
sparked her.
Yeah.
Got It from mom.
There's just a ton of,
you know,
I,
as I was going through these,
I don't remember where I let read the,
um,
you know,
I don't remember where I'd read this letter for the first time from Michelada
horror.
Cova but there's so much
good stuff in there.
Choose your friends carefully.
I'm interested just when she's kicking it off,
you know,
life is hard.
It does not pamper anybody.
That's a good thing for kids to understand.
Yeah.
You know,
welcome to life.
It's going to be hard.
Get accustomed to it,
but don't let it defeat you.
Boom.
Yeah.
That changing of your opinion.
One was,
yeah,
new powerful online and admitting when you're wrong.
Hey,
if I made this decision,
if I made,
if I had the wrong theory,
that's okay.
Yeah.
Just give me information,
new information.
Here we go.
I'm changing.
That's okay.
That was kind of freaked me out with politicians.
I think we've had this conversation,
we've had this conversation before.
Politicians,
people say,
oh,
he's a flip flop.
Flip flop or,
yeah,
and that's a negative thing.
It's a negative thing if the person is flip flopping just to get votes,
but as new stuff comes to light and they say,
you know what,
I kind of changed my opinion on that one.
Yeah.
Or the culture shifts,
man.
Like there's certain things that even,
I mean,
back to your thing,
but the short shorts,
that's,
I mean,
point here is a little bit different,
but you have to contend with cultural shift.
For me,
like in,
in Hawaii for example,
when I grew up,
like just the swimsuits,
um,
we're,
you know,
sure you wear a bikini,
but it's like a normal bikini.
So I come,
I go to college,
I come here and move here,
I go back.
This is like,
you know,
10,
11 years later I'm noticing the Bikini's in there.
It's just way less material and I'm like,
Dang this.
They're showing a lot,
but everyone's just,
you know,
little kids and stuff like that.
I'm okay.
And my younger brother who lives there,
he said,
that's just how it is now.
He's like,
man,
you,
you wouldn't have gotten away with some stuff that I had to like go,
okay,
I'm not going to expend a bunch of leadership capital fighting.
Not just my kids,
but fighting culture as a whole.
Yeah.
That's,
then there's things that crossed the line,
right?
Yeah.
I'll tell you,
are you wearing those short shorts?
That's bad.
You're gonna want to see me in those short shorts.
You don't want to have that happen.
So,
um,
like I said,
ton of good information from cap and Isaacson from
Dr Horell Cova.
Um,
but you know,
speaking of learning and teaching and questioning,
speaking of question time,
sure.
I think we got a little question time to contend with who Q.
And A.
Yeah.
Might as well
ask Jocko some questions.
Let's do that.
I like your answers to questions.
Junk.
See that's kind of the good thing about knowing your phone number.
I can just text you with questions,
my own questions,
a gross mismanagement of your time essentially.
However,
I'm pretty quick to answer abruptly and short answers because you pretty much
know what the answer is going to be.
I do.
And sometimes you just need that backup and that's,
or that,
that,
that reinforcement.
You know how like you're like,
man,
I really having this issue with myself.
Whatever you like.
I'm going to,
I'm going to ask Jocko one cause it's really,
I'm really confused.
Not Confused,
but you know,
I'm really,
I need the answer.
I don't have the,
I'm really,
when I'm going to ask Jacqueline,
you can be texting Jocko the answer or the question and you're like,
I know that like as I'm reading this question to Jocko,
it kind of puts it in so don't send it.
So you get about maybe a third name,
like a quarter.
The questions
that I actually started for you.
Yeah,
that's good.
Yeah man.
It's the good,
the chocolate fact.
Israel question number one,
Jocko.
I keep trying to ask around my BJJ school,
if anyone follows s NC program.
Did you just abbreviate SNC know what that is,
right?
No.
Oh,
it's strength and conditioning.
Okay,
sure.
100% that's like a known that that's a known thing.
Especially for someone that's jacked like yourselves into strength and
conditioning.
I don't write,
I've never seen that.
Maybe don't write that.
Maybe I just do it through credit.
Mike drop.
You can go home now.
Anyway,
I'm asking around my Jujitsu school.
If anyone follows a strength and conditioning program for comps,
which he has competition.
Nicely done.
You're up on,
everyone keeps telling me to just roll for strength and conditioning.
What do you think about that?
Okay,
so rolling is obviously the base.
Sure.
Right.
You need to roll and that that has to that this,
it doesn't mean include rolling.
Yeah.
Like we're going to go roll.
However it works out.
It means rolling with some kind of structure around it.
So you get your short rounds.
Okay.
You got to get your long rounds.
You got to get your shark tanks,
you got to get your positional drilling,
you got to get your consequence free.
Drills like Dean lister makes us do consequence free drills where you're going
to start in a position where you might get tapped out,
but it doesn't matter.
Right?
Right.
Or you're going to start a position where you might lose position,
but you're going to do it anyways.
And then Glover,
that's what Dean does actually.
Glover does the consequence drills where you're already stuck,
like starting in the arm lock that you're letting a person take your arm and
you're starting there and you're just gonna see what she can get out of it or
start in the triangle,
not the triangle.
Danger in the triangle.
That's some Jeff Glover,
you know,
we did that together.
Crap right there.
But it's good for you.
It's good.
So you gotta,
you gotta do that.
You don't end the short rounds.
By short rounds,
I mean short,
intense rounds.
Yeah,
right.
If you,
I,
my attitude in a three minute round is completely different than my attitude in
a 20 minute round or even,
I mean the,
the ultimate,
and believe it or not,
my attitude in a 20 minute round is different from my attitude in a no time
limit round.
Really?
Yeah.
Right.
Especially because in regular training,
even if you get the submission,
if I submit you in four minutes,
I still got them new,
another 16 so I might go all hard for four minutes and get the submission.
But then I've got to go to another 16 minutes now.
So I'm going to,
I'm going to have some tactical now if we're now what's different is if it's no
time limit after four minutes,
I get you.
We're,
we're kind of done.
We can go again.
Yeah.
We can just be done.
Right.
I got you.
But if you get them in one minute,
we're probably going to get,
yeah,
it's like an MP.
Four minutes is probably going again too,
but like eight minutes.
So I might,
I might not submit you in one minute or even four minutes cause I want to get
you to a point where I know I'm just going to have to do this and wanted to die
and the psychology.
Uh,
but so yes,
you have to roll now you,
but you still need to get stronger.
Right.
And a classic example,
this is a big Andy Big Andy Berke,
right.
Great Jujitsu but wasn't super strong.
Yeah.
And I was,
I said to him,
hey,
we started doing pull ups,
start doing pushups and dips and squats.
Just start to him.
And he did,
he listened to me and in a matter of a month he fell completely different cause
he wasn't working on raw,
he was just rolling and he's rolling hardcore,
but just rolling compared to actually getting stronger.
I,
and then he went on to
power lifting and Olympic lifting and,
and now it's like,
okay,
I got to contend with actual strength and power here.
So that definitely makes a difference.
You know,
his skill was getting better,
but it wasn't,
I was feeling a skill getting better,
you know,
but we're all getting a bit of at the same time,
but all of a sudden he started getting stronger.
So strength,
that's the strength part right now,
the conditioning part,
same thing.
Jujitsu allows you to rest and that's actually a positive attribute of your
Jujitsu game.
If you can rest while you're doing it right,
that's well that's one of the good that that proves that you know what you're
doing now,
that's actually a negative when it comes to working out.
Because if you do something like a row or a bike or a sprint or a metcon workout
on a timer,
there are no mercy.
Slacking is not rewarded.
You're,
you're,
you're racing against the clock.
And so those things are gonna push you faster for longer periods of time.
Harder than just a role.
Well.
So bottom line
for strength and conditioning in Jujitsu,
yeah,
you got to do Jujitsu for sure.
Gotta be your base and then you've got to do strength training to get stronger.
That's deads and squats and cleaning jerks and snatches,
overhead squats and all the key lifts and do it.
That means doing singles and doubles and fours and fives and sets a 20 I mean it
means getting stronger
and then you got to work your metabolic conditioning and how do you do that?
You go hard,
you go metabolic conditioning.
You Do,
you do metcons,
right?
You mix in lighter weights,
doing more repetitions short,
and you've got to mix up the realms to going short rounds,
long rounds to Bob diener tomatoes.
Yes.
The tabata protocol,
I don't know the exact,
is their exact numbers?
An exact number,
exact number for the Tabata protocol?
Sure.
Is 30 30 nope.
20 seconds of work.
10 seconds of rest.
Okay,
so for me that's like the shortest rounds you're doing is 20 seconds of work,
10 seconds of rest.
Then you got all stu long rounds and then you do,
you know,
a lot of times I do three on one off for rounds.
That's a boxing,
right?
A lot of times I'm doing five on one off that's
MMA.
And then above that you start to get to Jujitsu,
which is 10 minutes one off.
But what's interesting is if you're doing a 10 minute round and then one off and
then another 10 year round in the one off,
that blurs into one big round.
So a lot of times when we're did got a guy that's competing with black belch or
uh,
or he's doing a 20 minute fight or a 10 minute fight,
a 20 minute 10 minute grappling match,
one round of 10 minutes or one round of 50 minutes,
you've got to have him take a bigger break in between sometimes during the
training so that they're actually coming in,
they're fresh and they can work through the problem again.
Otherwise they're just going through the one hour role level the whole time,
which is not good for him.
Um,
and obviously you got to learn technique.
You're gonna practice technique cause Jujitsu is what's going to win.
And like I just had somebody hit me up on social media and they said,
cause I,
I told the story at some point on this podcast about rolling with a black belt
girl for the first time was the first time I ever rolled with an actual
blackbelt grown.
I was,
thanks,
sinking all,
you know,
I better bring my a game a little bit so I don't get caught here.
And then I want to,
as soon as I started rolling with,
I was like,
that's not happening.
And the guy says,
does this mean that you can't defeat a stronger opponent with Jujitsu?
And I said,
no,
absolutely.
I watched girls lighter,
weaker girls tap out,
bigger,
stronger guys on the regular.
But what were,
what,
what that situation was not only was I bigger and stronger,
but I'm also skilled at Jujitsu.
Yes.
So it doesn't apply.
Yeah.
And there's this element of Jujitsu and this actually kind of goes back to,
um,
when Andy,
when you know,
when you get Andy with his,
his skill and technique and then you add some strength and conditioning to it
and it's like,
you know,
so what you do if you,
if you don't have,
if you're not big and strong,
you can't really believe anyone on the mat and bully.
I don't mean Billy,
Billy.
I mean like you can't just turn on this like you're saying if you're not.
Yeah,
yeah.
If you were saying Jeff Glover,
people cause I have,
well he bullies in in a different way.
So that's what I mean by bullied.
Like you can't just impose your strength on someone.
Well,
I'm going to have to disagree with you.
Impose your techniques,
I think.
Yeah,
I mean Jeff Glover will bully guys on the mat if they're on the line for sure
hundred percent.
And it's in a different kind of way.
They were talking about you,
well you can't go strength.
You can't just start bullying.
Physically bullying.
Yeah.
You have to technically bullied up.
Yes,
I'll accept that.
So let's say your technique is,
is similar,
but you have straight up weight,
strength and conditioning.
It really plays a big chapter for sure.
And not to say that you'll be able to necessarily top the guy out,
but him trying to tap you out when you have strength conditioning,
insides,
size,
it's like it,
it just gets real hard for sure.
And then less you love you.
The key component there that you mentioned is that I have to have similar,
yeah,
cause you can be a 235 pound like guy,
super strong athlete.
And if you don't know Jay Jujitsu,
Jeff Glover is going to wrap you up.
Like you don't even know what's happening and he's 150 pounds.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah.
And He,
and I've seen him with that obviously with what,
roughly 100% certainty.
Yeah.
Well I,
you know,
even beyond roughly 100% he is really,
really close to 100% if you don't know Jujitsu,
245 pound muscle head going against Jeff Glover,
you're getting tapped out.
And if you do know what you just said,
there's the area for sure.
There was a video I think is grapplers quest.
I think it's still online right now.
Jeff lower gold goes against this huge guy,
that's for sure.
I think he was maybe,
and that guy knew something.
And you did sue fighter.
Yeah.
It was a Jujitsu match and hell man,
it's,
yeah,
it's just crazy to a lot.
That was when Jeff was like 13 or so
and he was crazy back then.
He's still crazy.
But yeah.
Um,
yeah,
so the girl,
the girl thing,
and I remember that question,
it was on Twitter,
right?
Yeah.
It was like,
Hey,
it doesn't do you do to allow you,
yes.
Yeah.
So they get,
yeah,
perfect.
Exact.
I mean that's the answer there because yeah,
you have all this experience,
but you know how like how we always talk about like when you lock up with
someone,
you know,
you can get a really good idea of what they're about to bring to you.
This is James Nielsen and you lock up and you're like,
what is it about?
This should be pretty easy.
All I'm getting swept for sure.
For sure.
There are exceptions for sure,
but generally speaking,
you know,
even just not even beyond just strength strengthen and their grip in their
rigidity and then you don't feel the,
you can feel the either like they're,
they're relaxed.
To me that's an indicator.
Yeah.
Someone that just likes one of them.
They feel relaxed.
You're like,
okay,
this is,
this guy probably knows what he's doing because the person that doesn't know
what they're doing,
they're going all psycho.
Yes.
Doing,
making like little micro moves that are incorrect,
you know?
Yeah.
Just even putting their foot right there.
It's like,
Bro,
your split should not be right there right now kind of thing.
Yeah.
You can tell real quick.
So,
but it does go into the strength part as well.
So like,
you know when you grab someone's wrist or they grab your wrist or something like
that,
you're like,
okay,
because you just said this is weird.
A lot of Jujitsu is knowing what's important and what's not in first.
So you know these,
that's not just jujitsu either.
Let's talk about that with,
with kids and with me,
a leader when you want to expand your leadership capital,
trying to get your Dick trying to get your team to do something that's not
really truly necessary.
Yeah,
that's not going to help your cause.
It'll,
and it's not going to help you in Jujitsu if you're focused on something that's
not important.
And to know what's important and what's not is very important as a leader,
as a parent and as on the Gigi to play or Matt of Justice and,
and very hard by the way,
it takes like a lot of experiences.
So you consider these guys who are,
um,
like if you do a light roll with a really,
really high level guy,
that's when you can start to see,
okay,
this guy really thinks that this arm position is really important because he'll,
he'll fight to the death to kind of maintain it,
you know?
So,
but what the back just back to the girl real quick.
The girl's situation,
when you lock up with someone's strength wise,
you know,
you feel like I said you what they're about to bring.
So again,
and when you have,
the more experience you have,
the more you're going to know with more accuracy.
And I think that's what you need.
And actually this point of taking that point and transferring it into leadership
is so critical.
And I'll tell you,
I am really good at knowing what's important and what's not and just be,
and you can see people that get all spun up about things and you know,
just okay,
they're spun up about something to do.
The same thing with family life.
You know,
your,
your wife gets all spun up about something and I'm like,
oh,
what are we going to do?
We're going to keep doing what we're doing and we're going to be okay.
You know,
Oh,
you want to focus all your time and energy on that?
That's fine.
Go ahead.
You know,
and that's cool.
I'll support you and you can make it happen.
But you know,
think about how important something really is when you're getting spun up about
something.
Just think about how important it really is.
There's a good chance it's not that important.
There's a really good chance it's not that important.
Yeah.
There's usually four or five things that are really important as a leader that
you need to focus on that list.
The further you go down that list,
the less important things are.
And I see leaders get spun up on things that are in the list on the list,
number 47 and they're acting like it's the most important thing and it's going
to ruin everything.
And it's like,
no,
it doesn't.
Not that big of a deal.
Yeah.
So learn that.
Is that why you wear the same clothes every day?
You know,
I wear the same because fashion is not important.
It's not important to me.
Those short rounds or good,
when you do short rounds and you'd get to and they kind of trick you too.
Jeff will do that.
He'll be like,
oh,
three minute rounds.
So you'd have this thing in your head like,
oh,
it's only three minutes.
Just go hard.
But meanwhile you only got 30 seconds rest before you got to go again.
So you're doing essentially a metcon do you do too.
That's good.
That is good for that kind of stuff.
Yeah,
man.
It's good.
Yeah,
I agree.
I like the straight.
Someone got,
some guys say you don't need strength and conditioning because the more the
anytime you spend doing physical activities should be on your Jujitsu.
They said,
it's interesting.
I would like to group that.
It sounds good,
but I would do,
if I'm going to do Jiu Jitsu six hours a day,
I'd still do strength and conditioning 20 minutes,
half an hour,
45 minutes.
That's one of the good things about you did.
So you can have different philosophies and still be successful because there's,
that is true.
I think like Dylan Dennis or something.
Maybe Marcel.
Marcel Garcia only does gene and dean used to always try and convince me that
it's going to do Jitsu.
Yeah,
and I'd say no.
We'll dean talk crazy strong though.
I know he's easy to say.
Oh,
I don't know.
I don't do grip strengths writing.
I can hold them for a full six hours.
So check.
All right,
next question Jocko.
I have a question about leadership.
I'm a firefighter and some one of the guys on my department have been pushing me
to step up,
input in for an officer's position and I'm honored.
But when we're one,
when we were going to a call,
I was presented with an opportunity to lead and passed it up.
I didn't know what I was thinking.
I can't believe I did that.
Did I just lose credibility if I did?
Is there
Oh,
was to get back that back away,
right?
That's what he meant.
If I did,
is there a way to get that back
sex?
Okay,
so first of all,
this is just a general rule.
If you want to lead,
always be ready to leave,
right?
Be ready to step up.
Make sure you're not stepping on people's toes as always,
but be ready to lead.
And the way you do that,
as you think about you,
what you do in certain situations,
you should always be thinking about that.
You should be thinking,
even if you were a trooper or a follower in a certain situation,
you should think,
okay,
well how would I leave?
What would I do right now?
What moves would I make?
What would I do if for contingency happened right now and what are the possible
contingencies that I can be looking at?
What are they?
And if you're thinking that as a,
as a
frontline guy,
when the opportunity pops up and then just jump on it and boom,
there you go.
Then when it does happen,
of course you got to stay detached because you want to make sure that you don't
lead too far.
You don't overstep your bounds and step on toes.
You've got to be careful of that.
So you need to live with that mindset and that will make you such a better
leader when the moment does come.
If you're always thinking about if you're always watching,
like he talked about earlier,
I'm watching the leader,
I'm seeing what they're doing,
I'm seeing what I might do differently.
I'm still supporting them.
I'm supporting you.
If you're in charge,
I'm supporting you,
but I'm thinking I might,
I might do this,
and then you watch what would my,
what would the results of my decision had been compared to what they did?
So you,
you can be thinking like leader even though you might not necessarily be in a
leadership position.
So live with that mindset.
That's what you need to do.
Now as far as you passing up the opportunity
to lead,
which yes,
you're admitting was an error.
First of all,
I'll say this,
it probably,
it's probably not quite as obvious to everyone else as it is to in your mind you
if they get all man,
I blew it.
This was my chance and PR.
No,
I bet the guys went back from that call and didn't even think about it.
Didn't even think about it again.
Most likely,
unless it was just some flake rent.
I don't want to lead.
I wrote already.
If you did that well then yeah,
people are going with that.
But if you just said,
if you just kind of backed away from a moment and people,
people might have realized it.
But anyways,
regardless of that,
you probably guess what I'm gonna say.
Then what you gotta do is own it.
Right?
You got to own it.
Hmm.
So when the opportunity presents itself to explain what happened and what went
wrong and what you did wrong,
right?
Not Making excuses,
but explain where you were weak,
you know,
so you say,
hey guys,
you know,
hey,
remember that last call I should have stepped up and I had to have the wrong
mindset.
I wasn't ready to lead and I let it.
Not only did I let you guys down,
I let myself down and I'm not going to let that happen again.
From now on,
I'm going to have leadership in the front of my mind.
That's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to be thinking about what needs to get done.
I'm rethinking about contingencies and how I'm going to lead,
and I promise the next time this opportunity comes up,
I'm going to be ready to lead.
So I'm sorry for letting you guys down and won't happen again.
Okay?
That's,
that's it.
Boom.
Get the mindset live and think as a leader,
regardless of what position you're actually in,
and then when they call you in,
the operative tunity presents itself.
Step up and lead.
Obviously that's your default mindset now.
Yes,
it seems obvious to me.
It is truly was it always like that?
And even before,
it's that story that I've told over and over again about being on an oil rig and
covering up and guys not knowing where to go or everyone freezing and me going,
okay,
let me just to step back and look around and make a call.
And when I did that,
that was it.
And so I clicked it clicked or I would say,
I guess I was thinking about it beforehand because I was,
you know,
observing my leaders and thinking about what they were doing and what I would do
differently in a certain situation.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
Cause even in everyday life,
which is what I represent everyday life,
but you know how you life or girl,
whatever is like,
Hey,
well you know,
what's the dinner situation?
What do you want?
Oh I don't care.
Whenever you want.
You know,
that's a time where I,
I always feel this,
what this guy just asked,
you know,
I mean obviously it's nothing compared to his situation,
but they're like,
hey,
well,
you know,
what are you thinking for dinner kind of thing.
And I'm like,
Hey,
I don't,
I don't care.
And that's really how I feel.
I'm done kind of down for whatever and of thing.
But that's not why,
that's not why she's asking me.
She wants me,
she wants me to make that decision.
She wasn't mean to take stuff up and lead,
step up and be like,
this is what we're having for dinner.
I'm going to go get her,
I'm going make it or whatever.
That's
what she wants.
And really those little,
those,
that situation comes up all the time.
Like you know the old that the Joe actually,
that's kind of like a joke.
You know,
when you ask the girl when a girl says,
or when you ask her,
hey,
what do you want to eat?
And she says,
I don't,
I don't care.
Whatever.
And then you say,
okay,
we're going to go eat here because they,
I don't really like that.
Of course.
See?
Yeah you got to,
yeah.
I feel like this guy when,
when I do that though,
that's the point.
They're now under going to step up and I'm going to do it yet but I want it to
be my default is why you don't like yours is like your default I into Oh this is
what we're doing.
There you go.
Okay.
That was true with her when it did come to dinner actually know what kind of is
true cause I only go to like three places to eat.
Yes.
And I go to one 80% of the time.
Yeah.
Same here.
The other 20% of the time.
So if she says where you want to go,
I'm here to say that my restaurant,
we're going to Ragland's in ob.
But that makes it harder though,
right?
Wait,
does she like Ragland's though?
She does.
She does and it makes it easier,
easier but and if she doesn't feel like it then she'll be like,
I don't really want to go there.
Okay,
cool.
Now it's on you.
I gave you my vote.
Right?
You don't want to do that,
but I think you still got to do it.
You still gotta make a decision.
You got to like,
cause in a way I'm in the same boat as your second scenario there.
Like if she's not in there,
so then I'm just going to name my secondary restaurant.
Alright,
there you go.
Just maybe she'll say yes.
Maybe she'll say no.
Wow.
That gotta be my default now though.
Step up and lead.
You know what it,
you know what I've gotta do?
I've got to prepare.
I've got to prepare myself.
Well,
yeah,
I got to have like five options just ready to go on deck.
That's what I have.
Three slope.
So that's not what you want to and they all come in the same order.
I must be really boring.
Hey,
you focus on what's important.
That's good.
Well,
whenever my wife says,
uh,
you know,
well don't you ever want to try anything new?
I said,
nope.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't.
Yeah.
Speaking of which Darlin
you're my girl and I'm looking to try anything new on me.
I'm happy with what happened,
man.
The same thing.
Very happy.
Yes.
That's actually that.
I'm going to use that later there,
but what do you do when the team wants to try something new?
All right,
let's rock and roll,
right?
Let's do that.
Good tips.
All right,
next question,
Jocko.
I'm a sergeant in my cow countries army.
The reason that I'm sending you this message is because of a tragic incident in
our unit this week.
A young enlisted soldier committed suicide.
He shot himself with his issue rifle.
This came as a shock to all of us.
He was a bright,
smart and happy guy.
Damn,
I'm seeking your advice.
Jacqueline,
do you have any advice on how I as a leader can talk to the guys about it?
How does a group of soldier soldiers cope with a loss when the reason is so
tragic?
Thank you.
In obviously condolences to
the team,
the and the family of the soldier.
And I think what you have to do in this situation,
as you got up as a leader,
you got to bring this out in the open.
I to think of one of the worst things you can do is pretend that it didn't
happen.
Pretend that the problem's going to go away.
And I think what you have to do is you have to explain it,
which is weird because in this case explaining,
it means admitting that you can't explain it because you can't explain it or
you're not going to be able to,
are you going to be making up something that you're guessing at it?
Right?
You're not going to know what individual,
what individual situations caused this to happen.
You know,
cause who can make sense of that?
I mean a bright,
smart,
happy guy.
It doesn't make sense.
And,
and,
and wow,
you can't explain why you,
I think you have to address it as a reality.
Okay.
And I think you've got to address it as something that you're pulled tuned,
needs to fight against.
Just like they would fight against the enemy.
What is the threat?
The threat is depression.
The threat is loneliness.
The threat is helplessness.
The thread is feeling like there's no way out.
And being aware of those threats is what allows recognition of the enemy is so
that you can fight him.
So I think you've got to talk about this with your guys.
I think that they will become aware of what they need to look out for in others
and in themselves
so they can alert the platoon that you know,
John,
Hey,
have you guys talked to Johnny man?
He seems,
you know,
Johnny seems a little off right now.
We should check in on them.
We should talk to him.
Or self recognition,
man.
I'm feeling like depressed about something.
I'm feeling dark.
It doesn't,
I don't know what I'm going to do.
Right in on that last podcast that we did,
I read a couple excerpts in words from some various combat veterans and I
touched on the fact that several of them from different times from different
wars had written the same thing.
And they wrote basically that death would be liberating.
Hmm.
And that it would be an escape from the hell of war,
from the memories of war.
And,
and I should have hit on that harder.
Okay.
Because
I think that what that means to me,
what that tells me is that
is that having those thoughts doesn't necessarily,
that there's something wrong with you.
Right.
It doesn't necessarily mean that you're losing it.
These,
you know,
the,
the writings that I'm talking about,
the book and then the writing from a guy that I knew,
it doesn't mean that you're losing it.
And I think that people think to themselves,
oh,
I'm,
I'm thinking about how death would be an easier way right now and [inaudible].
And they think that by thinking that they're,
they're totally screwed up.
When I think the realities that is on,
I even think the reality of the situation is that that's obviously a fairly
normal thing to think about.
And you know,
I,
when I was in Ramadi,
I definitely,
I wasn't thinking about killing myself,
but I definitely saw that dying in combat was,
would be a relief to the stress that I was under.
No doubt.
And I didn't want to die.
But I'll tell you what,
we joked about it.
I joked about,
I joked about it with life.
I'd be like,
Hey,
if we get in a firefight tonight,
first thing we do is crack a green chemist on my chest so the enemy knows
exactly where I am.
It's like we're joking because we're under a lot of stress.
But I think my,
what I'm trying to say is that those feelings or those thoughts don't mean net.
You're done.
They just mean that you're human.
Hmm.
And I think if you keep them bottled up,
then they might explode.
So that's what I think you need to do.
I,
that's what I need to tell your men,
that these thoughts happen and that your pull tune,
your team needs to be on guard against them.
And the best way to be on guard is to be vigilant,
to look for the signs,
to look for behavior and talk about them,
and then be able to ask for help.
That's one of the big problems is guys don't want to ask for help because we're
macho.
I don't need help with anything.
We are,
our egos are too big,
so we don't ask for help.
Hmm.
And so we have to put our egos in check.
We got to pay attention to each other.
And there's to be some people that you're going to have to pry this out of them.
Right.
They're not going to willingly talk about it.
So I think that's what you have to do so that you can get somebody to some
professional help.
I'm not a psychiatrist obviously.
And,
and in a normal infantry platoon,
there's no psychiatrist in there.
But you need to recognize,
cause you're the first line of defense and how can you get that to somebody,
to a professional that can help them.
And to be honest with you,
this doesn't only apply to soldiers,
right?
It applies to everyone.
Don't let these thoughts fester in your brain.
You got to get 'em out.
You've got to put them out in the light,
right?
You've got to put them out in the light.
So they,
so they dry,
they're like a vampire.
They dry up and they wither and they,
they turned to dust.
Hmm.
You know,
that's what you want to do.
You're gonna expose him so you can get the professional help and get things
under control.
So that's the leadership.
Be Straight forward with your troops.
Tell them the truth.
Explained the enemy threat.
That's what we're talking about and how you as a platoon are going to look out
for it.
And then obviously you've got to grieve the loss.
You've got to mourn your fallen comrade and then you also have to get back to
work,
get back to soldiering,
get back to preparing for the enemy that you will face on the battlefield with,
with a new awareness that there's a nother enemy that can lurk inside the
platoon and inside the individual and that you have to protect each other just
like you protect each other from a real enemy.
So that would probably be the,
the route that I would go.
Good luck brother.
With that.
This,
uh,
it's a hard one for sure.
Next question,
Jocko.
My leader is not an extreme ownership disciple.
Among other things.
He's fostering division within our team.
How do I help lead those who no longer trust in the commander but are awesome
guys want to stay involved?
How do I bring them back into the fold without threatening our lead or our dear
leader?
All right,
well first of all,
you gotta become a buffer between your boss and your team.
That's what you need to do.
Um,
try and absorb as much negativity as you can and make sure you don't spread that
negativity,
right?
This also,
this is a delicate situation that we've talked about before.
If you completely support the boss
and,
and act like the boss is the greatest person in the world,
the team is going to reject you or does it like a high likelihood that they're
going to reject you.
At the same time,
if you completely reject the boss,
then you've actually aided in dividing the team because now the team is not
aligned with the boss.
So you have to balance,
you have to balance this and one of the best ways to do this is to put listen to
us.
You got to pull the importance of the mission and the team above the egos and
attitudes.
So here's,
I'm going to say something like,
look guys,
I know we have our differences with the chain of command on some things,
but we have a job to do.
All right.
We have a mission to accomplish and even though we might not agree with the boss
on everything,
it's our team.
It's our team and the performance of the team.
Sure.
It reflects the boss,
but reflects us too.
Yeah.
So what I say we do is a win.
Let's,
let's win.
Let's be the best regardless of what the boss does or what the boss says,
To prove.
Yeah.
To prove that even with a situation where the leadership might be lacking a bit,
we're so good that we're going to win anyways.
Who wants to get some of that right?
Yep.
There you go.
Let's win.
Despite poor leadership.
That's what we're going to do.
Anything.
I'll tell you what,
in my younger and maybe a little less
politically savvy days,
I would've said something like,
let's win.
Not just despite our leadership,
but let's win to spite or the or ship.
Like we would just perform so well in the face of a horrible leader and we're
going to show everyone what was that?
The underdog Cinderella story.
We're going to rock.
So that's cool.
You know,
sometimes you're,
you're winning not just despite your leadership,
but to spite them.
I'm done that a couple of times in my career.
Not,
not the best,
if not the best one.
It's better to win despite them.
So despite we got some rough leadership,
it's okay.
And the other thing is,
you know,
you,
even when you're doing that with a bad leader,
you still got to be careful about stepping on the leader's toes.
And the way you do that,
it's really easy.
You give him all the credit,
you give them all the credit and that's great.
And that little nagging voice that you've got in the back of your head that
wants credit and you know that one I'm talking about that you go back there,
don't worry about that.
I'm telling you right now,
you will get the credit in the long run.
You will get the credit.
Don't worry about it.
You might not get the credit on this one,
or even this week,
this month,
maybe not even this year.
But eventually you will get the credit and recognition that you deserve that you
want because your boss's boss.
Yeah,
he knows what's up.
He knows what's up and your troops know what's up.
Okay?
And so when everybody knows what's up,
when you have a truly bad leader,
the truly bad leader doesn't,
they're hot.
They're not just walking around fooling everyone in an organization.
It's not happening.
And if it does happen,
it doesn't happen for a long.
Yeah,
it only happens.
There's a limited time that it can happen for,
because every,
every idiotic move that that leader makes down the chain of command,
at least one out of every five,
he does something stupid up the chain of command to.
And so how was that the group performance?
Oh,
well,
we know it's not the leader.
He's a,
he's an idiot.
Oh,
they must have some good junior leadership in there.
Who's those guys?
Oh,
that's Echo Charles.
He's in charge of that squad and they're crushing it.
So don't worry about that.
Just lead
in when and give that credit away and it's going to come back to you tenfold.
That's what she do kind of in a way goes back to like people are watching,
they're watching for sure.
Yeah.
You are a leader.
He's a poor leader.
People are going to pick up on that.
Yeah.
And the [inaudible] do you know that doesn't mean that the boss's boss is going
to advertise that because the Boston,
Boston,
there are a good leader.
Yeah.
So the Boston,
Boston,
you would come to undermine them.
Yeah.
No,
but when the time comes from emotion and when the time comes for a
reorganization,
that's what it's going to be happy.
You know?
That's where the,
that's where the adjustments are going to be made.
Yeah.
Good point.
But we get so wrapped up,
we get the ego gets yet ego gets you kind of watch out for that thing.
Okay.
Yeah.
To truly let it go.
When you don't get the credit and you for real think that you deserve the credit
to truly let it go.
There's the challenge.
Yeah.
That's a challenging one.
Relish in that challenge.
A laugh at it.
Yeah.
Do you know good boss?
You did awesome.
Good job.
Yeah,
because I,
well I feel like anyway when that does happen,
you know when something,
and it's not even necessarily someone else gets the credit for what you did,
it's just that like something big happen and it just went completely unnoticed
that,
that it was straight up because of you.
Right.
That's a potential scenario.
But let's say you,
you don't say anything.
I think that there is a small feeling of satisfaction that you're like,
you know,
you took the higher road and saying,
please get that for them.
Maybe that's my ego.
Yeah.
Well look at me over here.
I'm not even saying anything.
I'm giving away so much credit.
I'm the man that's like the perfect of money.
Ego or perfectly directed ego.
But cause usually it's eclipsed by the fact that you didn't get your credit.
Yeah.
Usually.
Yeah,
for sure.
It's hard.
We all want the credit.
Got To work on that
check.
Next question.
I have a question about the warrior mentality.
I recently was dumped on a deployment and it's difficult now that I'm home state
side.
How does a warrior handle this?
Is it like any other emotional loss?
I'm trying to use this loss and get after it and improve myself mentally and
physically.
Not sure how to properly submit questions to a podcast.
All right,
so the dear John Letter,
the old classic dear John Letter.
Hey,
and you know,
agree.
Sometimes you can keep it at bay when you're deployed,
but then when you get home and you get back to the places,
the familiar places where you have the mess specific memories,
that's,
that's where the pain starts to come in.
And that's fine.
You know,
that's,
that hurts.
That's,
we get that.
Um,
but in my opinion,
I've said this before,
the person that you built in your mind,
the person that you had a relationship with,
that you built in your mind,
that person doesn't actually exist.
They're not real.
She wasn't who she appeared to be.
And she isn't who she appeared to be.
She isn't the sweet understanding,
fun person that you cared so much about.
That's not her.
That's your memory.
That's what you built in your head.
She is actually the selfish self centered person that cares about herself first
and doesn't care about you.
That's the reality.
Yeah,
and that's fine.
Okay.
But a lot of times the pain that we feel isn't based off the reality.
It's based on the fantasy.
So you're feeling pain of losing something that wasn't real.
So let the fantasy go.
Remember that she is not the perfect person that you built in your mind,
period.
She's not.
Otherwise we wouldn't be in this situation right now.
Okay?
And then move on,
brother you had after and work out.
Train hard,
go digit you hike,
run up,
play guitar.
Just get after it.
And those things.
Not only are you going to distract you from the pain,
which is good,
they're going to improve you as a human being,
which is good.
And they're gonna rebuild your confidence,
They're going to make you feel good.
They're going to make you stronger and smarter and better and puts you into a
place where you don't need that little made up fantasy anymore.
Yeah,
and they're going to put you in a place where you can find somebody better than
the fantasy.
Now,
I'm going to tell you right now,
the fantasies don't exist.
The perfect girl or guy for you doesn't exist.
They don't exist.
So you're going to be out looking for someone that's good,
but you're not going to find perfect.
Don't get obsessed with finding perfect.
If you find someone that's perfect,
it's not true.
Everyone's got their flaws.
So
that's what you have to do.
And,
and you will end up finding someone that's real and,
and I get it,
man.
I know you're going to have some moments
down in the hole as Alison chains put it or trapped in the heart shaped box as
nirvana put it.
Sure.
Or so lonesome.
You could cry as Hank Williams Sr put it,
does it.
You notice a theme here.
This is what people go through,
but those feelings,
they're temporary.
So let him say hi,
let them hang around for a minute or for half an hour or an hour or whenever and
then kick them out,
kick those feelings out,
get them out of there and go do something else.
Okay.
Did take your mind away from those memories of fantasies and put,
build some good memories that are real then yeah.
You know what?
You can use your anger and your frustration to fuel positivity.
For sure.
I spent much of my youth doing that very thing for sure.
All those break ups.
Yeah.
I turn those things into,
into fuel.
And the other thing I'm telling you is if,
if you take action with your body,
your mind is going to fall and pretty soon you'll be onto the next chapter and
you can move beyond this bad fantasy chapter that you kind of got roped into.
Man.
She can curls man,
he get you every time if you let them.
It's so hard to,
I mean with the so many times,
you know,
cause when I was a assistant between commander platoon commander tasks and
granted we're not,
we're not what I was doing.
Right.
But more in the earlier phases.
Cause then once I was,
you know,
a task unit commander I was dealing with a lot less.
Those,
those problems that would come to me on a relationship level would be something
big.
You know,
divorce,
a custody of children,
some kind of domestic violence scenario,
like real things.
But when I was younger and I was in a seal platoon,
that's when you're dealing with guys going through the breakup with a girl and
the,
you know,
the method method with my head.
Yeah.
It's messing with my head man.
Yeah,
of course.
Every guy goes through that.
Me,
you ever.
That's the way it is.
You get that weird thing kicking around in there and you'd start getting crazy.
And what's so funny is what's so funny is when you're on the outside of it,
it's like when you're in the heart shaped box yourself,
you just can't see anything else.
It's just a devastating,
and everyone that's looking at you as like,
Bro,
let's just go to the bar tonight and you'll meet 17 new girls tonight,
but I've like a bag.
I love that lag.
Or that was most special goal?
No,
it's not.
I remember I kind of had,
this is kind of evil,
but I had a kind of a standard response to guys when they'd say,
you know,
hey,
I broke up with Jennifer last night.
I mean off sweet man,
let's,
let's roll.
I would always,
and I even carried that,
honestly,
this is like not something I don't think I would do anymore,
but even when guys who would be like,
hey man,
me and Jennifer are getting divorced,
I'd be like,
oh,
right on,
bro.
You know,
I kind of,
and part of it was just to kind of spin it like,
guys,
man,
not the,
you need to,
you know,
you don't just wallow in it,
right?
You're getting divorced.
Okay,
here's what you need to do.
Here's how you maneuver.
But let let you know,
what are you going to do?
You're going to get dragged down by that into that Meyer,
or you're going to be,
you know,
salvage what you can have your life and let's move on.
Let's rock and roll.
Yeah.
So that's,
again,
it might be a little harsh.
I don't know that I would still have that react maybe with maybe fall still in
the Jews,
you know,
in most and 99 I had one guy that,
that that in,
I probably said that too.
We have a high divorce rate in the seal teams.
It's like an 85 90% divorce rate.
So I've said this to quite a few individuals over there.
Here,
I only had one that ever kind of,
you know,
was was like,
no man,
you don't get it.
And then I said,
no,
actually I do get it.
You don't get it.
Yeah.
And it always is a little rougher when there's kids involved and all that.
So that would put another little horrible spin on it.
But the bottom line is that is a good attitude to have hae broke up with my
girl.
Right on.
I'm glad I got out of this relationship before it developed into something where
I did have hooks in me,
financial hooks,
she old Drin,
all those things.
I made it out Scot free,
you know?
Oh,
I'm getting divorced.
Oh you have any kids?
No.
Okay.
Rock and roll.
You got kids,
okay,
well how's it going to go?
You know,
what are you put in line?
so definitely hard.
Here's a question.
Have you ever gotten your heartbroken and negative and you haven't a straight up
EVNA of course I was.
I was a boy.
Boys get their heartbroken.
Oh you know,
10 11
one ish time cause you don't,
when you're 10 it's like okay 1514 1713 I mean I think once I was,
once I was in the seal teams,
I kind of had that coping mechanism when you have,
because in the two years now we've got to be hard and the girls are like,
you know,
you gotta you gotta just kind of,
but the other y'all,
that's,
you know,
the younger days for sure,
every guy goes through that.
And that's what,
that's what's hard.
And you know what I'm saying guys specifically,
but the girls are the same way.
Both guys and girls go through these horrible breakups.
And,
and,
and this is the other thing that we got to realize as parents,
when you're 16 years old,
we,
you know,
I look at my 1516,
17 year old daughters,
right?
As they were growing up and,
and I think,
oh,
they got a boyfriend,
whatever he'll be,
this guy is meaningless in their lives.
I factually know that these guys are meaningless in terms of the broad spectrum
of their life.
Yeah.
But guess what,
when you're 15 years old and you've got a boyfriend that is your whole life.
And so when something goes sideways,
I had to say,
oh,
I do remember that myself.
When I saw my daughter's distraught over something,
I'd say,
okay,
here's what's going on,
but this is her whole life.
And I tried to explain to him,
this guy,
I understand that you like him and that he was good and blah,
blah,
blah.
But you know,
let's remember you're only 15 and they're,
you know,
you're going to meet another nice guy and there'll be other opportunities and
blah,
blah.
But the,
of course it barely,
barely gets through to their head.
They can't even imagine.
I was different.
I know because he's the bat.
No.
Yeah.
And so,
yeah.
Dang Bro,
you're,
you're on that question restriction from now on.
No Bro.
I want him to know,
I think we all wanted to know.
Next question
Jocko.
What's your take on false motivation versus authentic leadership?
Okay.
Falls motivations versus authentic leadership.
Now there's two kind of
two kind of ways of understanding this question.
The first is from like a really heavy leadership perspective and that is of
trying to lead without actually believing in what you're doing.
And that's leading without understanding why and not believing in what you're
doing.
And that's wrong.
Right?
And this is an extreme ownership of course.
And we talk about on the podcast,
you can't do it if you don't believe in what you're doing.
Your team's going to see that.
And they won't believe in it either,
which means they're not going to go above and beyond to accomplish the mission
period.
So you got to believe what you're doing and if you don't believe it,
then you got to ask the question off the chain of command.
Find out why.
Understand why.
So that you believe in what you're doing and eventually you're going to get the
answer right.
Eventually you're going to understand
why you're doing something.
You're going to believe in it,
or you're going to,
you're going to convince the chain of command that,
well,
that's not a good method and you need to go a different direction.
And there might be some rare in extremis case where you actually don't,
you know,
you're,
I'm being told to do something and I don't believe in it.
Yeah.
And I'd say,
no,
I'm not going to do it in,
like Napoleon said,
Napoleon's maxims.
If you,
you,
you actually have to refuse to do it.
If you don't believe it's the right thing to do,
then you don't do it.
That should be,
if very inextremist,
because are,
as a leader,
when we're being asked to do something or told to do something or lead in a
certain way,
they're,
they're leading us towards victory.
Right.
Right there leading us towards an aligned victory.
If it's on the battlefield,
it's winning the war.
If it's in business,
it's creating profit and creating good product and,
and growing the business,
right?
Those things are,
that's what you're trying to do.
So if echo,
if,
if I'm the boss and you come to me with a,
with something and say,
Hey,
I want to do this.
If it's going to make us more profitable,
why would I say no?
Right?
So we're going to move in that direction.
Um,
so from a high level,
false motivation doesn't work.
If you don't believe in something that's not going to work out for you.
Now,
yeah,
from a micro level,
from like a front line level and the buds,
instructors used to joke about this,
that false met motivation is better than no motivation.
Have you ever heard that?
Is that a common expression?
False motivation is better than no motivation and we don't want that to be true,
right?
Because we want motivation to be this pure golden thing that fuels performance
button.
The fact of the matter is,
and of course we talk about all this all the time,
motivation doesn't hold up,
right?
Motivation doesn't know how many motivated people motivated people,
didn't make it through seal training a ton of them.
They're all motivated you.
How many of them didn't make it for training?
Autonomy,
how many motivated people do you see that don't accomplish their goals that they
have?
Right?
The world is full full of those people.
There's a ton of those people
and that's because motivation doesn't hold you up.
We all know this.
It's disciplined.
That holds you up.
It's discipline that gets things
going and it's discipline that gets you through things.
But this is a little interesting little spin if you have the discipline to press
on,
why not have a little fun with it?
Right?
And that's where I think false motivation can,
can come in and you can make sense.
Some things fun.
For instance,
it's cold,
wet and miserable and we have to go swim over the beach and do an operation.
Let's get some,
or it's a 118 degrees with massive humidity and we have a 14 kilometer patrol to
get to target.
Let's get some who Yahoo or the water is 41 degrees and we are about to launch
on a four hour dive,
right?
Hell yes.
Let's do this,
right?
That that's false motivation,
but it's backed up by discipline and it might not be real,
but it absolutely beats the hell out of this is going to be miserable though.
I want to do it right.
What would you,
if you and I were going to go do something that was going to suck,
would you rather have me say a echo?
I really don't want to do this.
Put some disciplines too.
I'm going to do it.
Or would you have rather have me say,
echo,
this is going to suck.
Let's go get some right.
You'd rather have the false motivation strap on the pack and put on the mask and
fins and fire up the false motivations here after it.
Now,
I will tell you this,
I wouldn't even be sarcastic with false motivation.
I won't even blink an eye accident.
My,
this is the difference.
My my faults.
Motivation doesn't believe a false.
I actually believe my own false motivation if it's working and by the time stuff
came out of my mouth,
I meant it.
So I don't know at some point in my childhood,
false motivation turned into like an actual fuel and just just regular
motivation.
Maybe it's because I realized that I wasn't counting on it to get me through
things.
I was just having fun with it.
Rock.
And do
you think also how you know how you,
like you'd always say that you were kind of into just being hardcore,
even if it's your normal style,
whatever.
So you know,
when you think back and you're like,
okay,
I'm going to take the hard route or whatever,
after you finish it,
you kind of feel more proud of it for sure.
Like do you think that that played into it?
That is like I can be,
yeah,
for sure.
For sure.
Be More hardcore.
Yeah.
Like I said,
like the meaning of the meaning of the music hardcore when I was a kid was being
hardcore and just the actual meaning of the word.
And so yeah,
it's real easy to go from that to like,
Hey,
I'm going to do something that's socks and I'm going to have a good time with,
I'm going to laugh about it.
And that does,
and it is contagious.
So contagious.
I'm actually not like that now.
And if would you say you're going to like,
no,
I'm actually like that now.
Oh,
okay.
Not to,
you know,
100%,
but in a lot of things man,
like my um,
my daughter,
she's four,
she weighs 45,
47 pounds.
So I'll be sitting here,
I'll be laying on the couch,
not paying attention.
She'll climb up on the couch behind and jump in land.
Like,
you know what a knee drop is,
right?
Atomic knee drop.
Just so you know,
for awhile in my house there was no rules in my house.
No,
actually there was no,
there was only two rules in my house when my kids were like,
when my older kids were like,
you know,
seven,
six whenever that,
those types of ages that your daughter out right now.
But a little bit older,
there was two rules in my house.
Number One,
don't touch me when I'm eating.
Number two,
no atomic knee drops.
They would do it to each other.
Oh yeah.
I didn't mind them doing it to me,
but they would atomic knee drop each other.
Yeah.
So I had to have two rules and plus I wouldn't have a lot of time to eat and all
of a sudden it's like they want to hold on my arm.
No,
no,
no word from you want a meeting like a,
like a rabid dog.
And it's funny,
one of them,
the reason that's fresh in my mind,
cause we were just on a trip and,
and you know,
my kids were explaining to my youngest daughter that,
well,
you know,
when we were little dad was meaner and he wouldn't let us touch him when we
were,
when he was eating.
Like you just did.
And of course I said,
well that's because she's cuter than you,
all of you.
I ended up,
I don't mind the time it knee drops anymore because of you,
because of the very reasons like you gotta be hardcore cause like,
okay,
you've got a four year old kid,
right?
Get how fun that is for her to,
I talk to the drop here,
which is another reason why I'm like this now.
So she'll climb on the couch talking to need drop while I'm not ready by the way
onto my ribs.
So she didn't break my ribs,
she didn't injure me to,
to any blasting degree.
But if the normal mindset is like,
why did you jump?
Why did you do that?
It hurt.
It's face it 45 47 pounds,
top of a couch.
Tomic need job.
Both of these,
by the way,
all the weight,
you know,
for the last city,
all that stuff hurt by the normal standard of things.
So the typical mindset I think would be like,
don't do that,
especially the shock and all this stuff,
but default is just like whatever.
No factor.
And Yeah,
sure it is a catch 22 cause she will and does and but she thinks it's all fun
and all this stuff.
But yeah,
that's that mindset and that came directly from you like Bihar.
It's like Jocko wouldn't complain about that right there.
Oh,
you want to let that happen.
It's really embarrassing if you complain to your four year old daughter,
you've heard anything about anything,
about anything.
I agree.
That's the setting example you were talking about earlier.
Yeah.
You complain about anything and you're wrong.
Agree thousand million.
Just suck it up.
Yeah.
Say bring it on.
Yeah,
false motivation,
which becomes real motivation,
which for be hardcore,
the only,
like I said,
the only sort of reason for motivation for me is just funny.
Just funny.
It's not going to actually get you to do anything but just let's have fun.
I'm going to do it anyways.
I'm going to let the atomic knee drops happen over and over again and I'm going
to end.
So why?
When I could go through life,
just experiencing them and accepting them,
wanting to have some fun with the atomic and he drops in the long cold dives and
those hot weather and the dehydration and the hypothermia.
Why not have fun with all those things?
Yeah.
I mean you probably know,
but it's unbelievable how much that helps you sell.
You know what I think maybe because my view of motivation is so low.
Yeah.
That to me it's just funny,
like false motivation,
like just funny.
Yeah.
And it,
but it is fun.
It's a fun thing.
Yeah,
that's,
and that's kind of part of what I mean k so that you know the mats,
I don't know if you noticed,
I brought the Mattson.
Yes I did.
So those mats there,
I think just like 16 of them,
I forget how many,
but they cover a two full two car garage covered it perfectly.
It's a lot.
It's a lot of math and the two inch thick ones.
So to move them up the,
you know,
the
topography is that even,
so you had,
so you had like some legit challenge and yeah.
And I'm not even saying that there's not enough here to here.
This is what happened.
He came in,
put the maths right there,
boom.
One day,
I don't know,
whenever the other day.
And then um,
you know,
I walked to Jade's office,
my brother,
you know,
he was like,
Oh hey,
what's up?
What are you doing here?
I was like,
oh just put the mats in there.
He's like,
you put the mats in here.
What do you do?
You go,
what did someone help you with that?
I looked at him and I said,
I don't need help.
Oh,
but it was a joke cause that's the line from this thing.
But the point there is just that,
that attitude,
you know,
like,
no,
I don't need help.
No I don't,
you know,
cause I'm trying to be like Jocko,
hardcore.
I don't need help.
Little kids can't hurt me.
You can't make me completely,
you know,
it's like that mindset.
But,
and it said his chair,
you're asserting into a complete savage,
little kids can't hurt you and you can carry the mass by your own mind,
your own,
that's another thing.
And this is another little expression that used,
cause my son,
when he could,
before he could talk,
well he would,
when he would want to do something he'd say,
he'd say,
I do it by my own,
by myself or on my own.
Yeah.
It makes it say by my,
so that'd be kids outgrow.
That became a thing.
Here's a legitimate one that that just changed.
It changed this specific thing where,
you know how I,
like I'd be the kind of,
I didn't get enough sleep.
I just let it ruin me mentally.
So if I didn't have something specific like,
uh,
important to do.
So just throughout the day,
oh,
I'm tired,
you know,
whatever.
So now I never admit that I'm tired.
Yeah.
That's,
that's a good,
great starting place.
I've used it myself.
I've explained that to my son.
Is,
is you just don't admit ever that don't want those words come out of your mouth.
Yeah,
I'm tired.
I'm sore and whatever,
just stop.
Because when you're getting the teams,
that's just,
uh,
putting up a red flag of being a complete pain.
You don't do it.
Don't do it.
As a matter of fact,
you know,
was jacked up.
It's like I won't even,
let's say you and I were to go out,
let's say it was wintertime and you and I were to go out and I had a sweatshirt
with me because I knew it might get cold but we're out already and I have the
sweatshirt in my hands.
I won't even put it on.
You can put it off cause then you,
then you might say,
well are you cold cold?
They need some warmth.
Yeah.
Dang,
that's a good one.
Yeah,
I'm going to do that too.
Should I say not do know,
remember that I remember,
I think I told this story before,
but every time we were joining from la he was like late at night and you're
like,
yeah,
I know I'm this big bed team guy or whatever,
but I'm kinda tired right now.
And then almost like you just,
it was painful to let the words out of your mouth,
you know,
like you let them slip in.
It really hurt you.
It was like maybe like three seconds later you said,
fuck it.
I'll just draft a Montana.
If I have to be right now,
I'll just get in the mood.
I was tired yesterday.
I was driving and my wife says like,
Oh,
you haven't been sleeping much.
Are you okay to drive?
I was like,
yeah.
And I actually,
I did the same thing.
I was Kinda like,
well,
I'm super tired.
I can drive indefinitely.
I don't know though.
The,
I mean you,
I dunno,
maybe you're different.
Maybe not,
but no,
no.
I don't encourage people doing that.
Don't encourage it.
That's a,
that's a horrible thing to do is drive when you're super tired.
Yeah.
Don't do that.
Well,
I'm coy.
It's um,
it's happened to me before,
but why it's really boring to drive because it's so easy.
It's just so like you don't,
so when you get like tired or sleepy or whatever,
it's really easy to just fall asleep.
Super easy.
And that's hard because you can't control it.
It's like you think you can just,
I can control it.
In short,
there is little tactics like you can like let her do little things that you
don't inflict pain on yourself,
whatever.
But man,
it's really hard to control once you fall asleep.
Don't do that.
You wake up in a bridge in bunk,
just dead or wake up dead.
Yeah,
that's not good.
I was reading this thing on motivation and it said in this book,
I'm not saying that this is true or not true,
but it said it made sense where motivation,
people misuse the word motivation and they confuse it with inspiration.
Inspiration is like when someone gets you all revved up to do something,
right?
It's like what you're saying like,
well,
you know,
let's do this.
Or you see a mansion now you're inspired to work hard for stuff or whatever.
Listen to some speech,
some quote unquote motivational speech.
It inspires me.
It doesn't motivate you.
Motivation is your,
your bare raw motive.
The motive for you doing it.
So let's say,
I feel like I said this before,
but the,
let's say I want to get in shape.
You know,
girls will get in shape for their wedding.
that's the motive is to be in shape for the wedding so that doesn't go away.
So she's not necessarily inspired,
meaning she's like,
um,
she got infused with some feeling,
you know,
if you just wouldn't go away,
but it would,
well,
no,
here's the thing.
The motive is still there is discipline.
Yeah.
There's a motivation.
She wakes up at five o'clock in the morning to go get a workout in before she
goes to work.
The real easy to just be like,
you know what,
I'm not feeling motivated today.
Right,
right.
Just get the,
get the wedding dress,
you know,
let out a little bit.
But that just means that the motive motivation,
the motive isn't strong enough to overcome her feelings for lack of inspiration.
I don't rely on it.
Yeah.
You're not going to find a motivation that's strong enough to make you do the
things that you have to do all the time.
You don't,
you can't,
doesn't exist.
It kind of,
well,
it depends.
It just depends.
So consider a fighter.
Stop.
Consider a fighter with a fight he has to make.
Wait.
Yeah,
you're right guys.
Don't make us wait on time.
That's what I'm saying though.
The motive and you know,
with that,
you know,
when that motivation failed,
that motivation failed.
You know,
five weeks ago when they,
when they guys burgers,
yeah.
They had a five guys burgers.
You're right.
Yeah.
So the discipline holds the line.
Yeah,
it does.
Totally.
Now you can have fun with it and you can be motivated to have discipline and you
can say,
Oh,
like a pee Robin from origin geese.
I was up with him in Maine and he's like,
got a bet to lose weight.
And he hit me with some false motivation because we were out,
we were out and you know,
we were ordering,
I was ordered a big steak and just getting after the Grub.
Sure.
And I said,
like,
how many more pounds do you have?
You know,
we're talking about,
and I was like,
it was kind of sock can sit here.
He's like,
no,
I actually enjoy watching you eat delicious food.
You go to false motivation coming at you,
but in a funny way.
Yeah.
And instead of letting it out like that instead of being just miserable,
why not just have some fun with it.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's great advice.
fully.
But then the difference though,
like I said,
I agree.
You're right.
I mean that's the point I was maybe making was uh,
was just the technical difference between motivation and inspiration.
You know,
hey,
you know you to know this stuff because both those words just flimsy.
They're weak words and their week ended and the actual subjects are weak
inspiration.
All right.
It's not going to get you there.
Come on.
It might get you through like the first three minutes of,
of,
you know,
you and I were just talking before you came in here.
You said there was moments in your workout today when you could have easily or
yesterday you could have easily called it like,
hey man,
I'm sweating.
I got a good workout.
But didn't you held the line?
Yes.
Discipline,
discipline.
It was actually I created false.
Just truth be told,
you're right.
But I've created false motivation for myself.
I just say,
you know what,
I'm going to,
I'm going to do this.
Actually,
it's the way for me to facilitate discipline for myself is I want to do this
cause I'm going to feel better afterwards.
You know,
that whole deal talking about discipline,
then you contrast it with how junk I'm going to feel if I don't weak embarrassed
for myself by the way.
And when I said that,
um,
you know how workout has many opportunities to stop.
So one,
the first opportunity is in the parking lot.
In this case I went to a gym.
So Bro,
if you walk away when you're in the parking lot,
you got to issue.
So I've done that.
I've done that like four times in my life to admit that on the podcast you
should just lie.
Boy,
it makes this current story.
Okay,
mercy again.
So boom,
that's the first opportunity.
Second opportunities before you warm up,
which is pretty close to the first opportunity before you won't ever quit then
yes.
Oh my God.
Jeez.
One time it felt real good cause they justified it,
but very effectively.
And the second time I was like,
I just gotta get after it tomorrow,
whatever.
Nonetheless then,
then it's after the first body part d or the first sort of,
you know,
you have,
I'm going to do,
you know,
metcon first.
I'm going to do spots first.
So,
you know,
it's after the first exercise body part.
Really that's one opportunity.
To me the biggest hurdle is getting there,
which,
which is when you have your gym in your house,
that's that turtles gone.
I agree that it gets easier to hold the line for sure after you start,
but there's a part at the end,
you know how like how you just said you'd like to do your,
uh,
Macron the afterwards.
No,
lately I've been doing metcon before and lifting heavy African,
right?
Yeah,
that's what I meant.
But you're right,
I could say,
you know what that meant come was a little bit heavier.
It was hard.
Just call it good on that day.
A heavy part.
Yeah,
exactly right.
But man,
I feel so good when I'm all loosened up.
Yeah.
So same deal with me and they,
uh,
every opportunity to quit was passed.
Was wave well done.
Echo Charlie,
last question here.
You got time for one more.
Yes,
Jocko.
I am a chronic excuse maker.
How do I stop making excuses and
get things done?
The chronic excuse maker,
how do you stop making excuses?
This is actually pretty simple.
Yeah,
and I said it the other day and you have to realize,
you have to know.
You have to,
except that all your excuses are lies.
They are lies.
All of them.
Think about the things that you tell yourself,
the lies you use to rationalize.
Taking the easy road,
taking the easy road and leaving discipline behind.
Think about them.
You don't have time.
That's a lie.
You don't have support.
You don't have the equipment or the gear.
Okay.
Lies.
You don't.
You don't know the best way.
Who Cares?
That's a lie.
Or you're too old or you're too young.
Of course you're too old or too young,
lie
and there's,
you're too busy.
Sure you are.
That's a lie.
And you're too tired or you're too sore or you're just plain not feeling it.
Lies,
lies,
lies.
Okay?
And the list goes on and on and on.
And it doesn't stop.
If you don't make it,
stop.
So recognize,
recognize
the excuses are not valid.
They aren't.
They're trumped up there,
conjured up.
They're fabricated,
they're lies.
And how do you stop the lies?
You Stop the lies with the truth,
the truth,
the truth will set you free.
The truth will stand and the truth will deliver you from Procrastination and
laziness and the downward spiral that comes with a lack of discipline.
So don't believe the lies,
believe the truth.
And the truth is you have time.
You have the skill,
you have the knowledge and the support and the willpower and the discipline to
get it done.
So cast out the lies,
burn them down
and listen to the truth.
They live the truth and go out and get it done.
And I think that's
all I've got for tonight.
So Echo.
Yeah,
speaking of the truth.
Sure.
Could you perhaps explain to us how to support this podcast if we want to,
if we want to be sure.
Yeah.
What you can do is support yourself.
[inaudible]
I think I made this analogy before,
you know,
in the aircraft,
right?
Pre takeoff.
We go through the safety instructions in event of cabin pressure loss.
Yeah,
oxygen mask comes down,
put it on yourself,
be free and all that.
I mean that's a good kind of thing.
Where are you support yourself then you can help support others.
So support yourself.
This is how we supplementation like it,
and again,
I'll say this again,
I'll say it every day.
If I,
if I am compelled,
if I'm motivated to inspired too.
Either way,
I'm now into supplements,
not a bunch,
but before I was like no supplements,
you just get good nutrition anyway.
So krill oil and I think this is a daily thing by the way.
And I think you can maybe relate,
I think daily on how happy I am that I take Krill oil,
but I don't like thank my lucky stars,
nothing like that.
I'm just saying there are daily things that it's on my mind that I'm like this
experience would be different if I didn't not take Krill oil straight up.
That is true.
So I got it.
So I backed my car into the garage loading mats,
the,
Oh yeah,
that,
that was another time.
But this was more recently.
So it's getting filling,
you know what,
you fill up the five gallon things a water.
Yeah.
And I talk about that.
So I'm putting it like you got to maneuver it because I sit in the garage,
I should've pulled out.
But whatever the new hardcore man be times on maneuver ain't got to take it out.
And I don't want to,
you know,
so you,
it's hard to explain,
but you don't when you're on base,
whenever,
whenever it's true,
it's apple.
It's applicable everyday life.
The krill oil isn't just for deep squats,
heavy [inaudible].
It's for taking five gallons of water in a jug out of tight spaces where you've
got to kind of twist,
you know?
Yeah.
Cause you don't want the car door to hit like the other car door got dented.
Good time to have the Krill oil in you.
Yeah,
man.
And,
and really that's,
well that's part of the payoff is what big part is the everyday things.
It's true.
For sure.
Yeah.
There'd be times where I'd be sitting down a long time and I stand up and I'm
surprised on how little pain I feel.
Pain,
you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
But you,
you ever been like that where you think like,
yes,
I'm going to feel like all this,
this is going to be stiffer.
This is going to be heard of what an end.
It's just simply not.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Dot.
Okay.
That part is real.
So get your Krill oil in the event of you,
even wine and Krill oil.
These are my experiences.
Obviously.
Jock was this walkers.
You take Krill oil as well.
Indeed.
Um,
get them from audit on it.com/jocko if you want the 10% off.
Also the Alpha brain.
So the crude oil,
that's like,
I don't think that'll ever go away.
No.
Okay.
The Alpha brain,
I am using a lot more.
Okay.
Murray,
the more to coincidence,
maybe,
maybe not one might be causing the other correlation.
May Not be causation,
but I'm just saying that is happening.
And I will admit this.
As far as workouts go,
I'm getting real into the kettlebells.
You've always been into the Kennel.
Yes.
Yeah.
Not always,
but no.
15 years you been in the game?
I would say like
maybe 10 years or something.
12 years.
Yeah.
Okay.
Maybe it has been 15 years.
Yeah.
Cause I just remember that picture Joe Rogan,
I think Joe Rogan and I were talking about the picture of Fado fader.
Yeah.
Look that up right when you guys were talking about with the pictures.
Oh,
okay,
cool.
Yeah.
Kind of hard to get them back then though.
Well yeah,
it's a,
I think it was your room and saying how like somebody introduced him to America
and that's,
that's where,
that's from.
Rushing guy.
Yeah,
man,
they're,
they're really good.
Um,
again,
being careful every single moment,
but I'm to the point right now where like,
you know,
you get kind of good and it gets even fun or like anything.
And then I'm like,
Oh,
let me get that heavier one.
Now let me get the heavier one.
But I will say this about the kettle bells,
about my experience.
I started off the kettlebells getting the these designer ones,
primal bells on it.
Zombie Bells Brag.
Actually I didn't get the Zombie.
I got primal and then the legend Werewolf once.
Anyway,
they're cool,
right?
Cool to look at.
So you know who I'm Kinda like,
I dunno how you should be proud of this or ashamed of this,
but I'm like the kid,
you know,
the teenager who gets their driver's license and there's two types of kids.
There's the one kid who the dad's like,
hey,
you got to learn to walk before you can fly.
So you got it.
Like,
I dunno all make the down payment.
You make the payments.
That's what my dad used to say.
Or You make the down payment or whatever.
You know,
like you've got to work for this first car and it might not be the,
you know,
the BMW,
whatever.
Then there's the other kid who rolls right into the BMW,
you know,
hey,
good job.
You're 50 now,
big,
big time of your life,
time in your life,
whatever.
Yeah,
here's a dope car.
Congratulations.
Love you son.
You know?
Then there's that guy that's kind of who I am with the kettle bells.
You know,
I didn't like pay my dues.
You know when the kettle bells were new and all the straight to
the dope where off.
Anyway,
a lot of cool stuff on there,
on the web,
on it.com.
A lot of cool stuff on there.
Um,
all legit stuff.
That's I think the,
the real compelling thing for me anyway because I know if he's supplements men,
I've heard of people getting their supplements and then you know,
the supplement was like contaminated with something and then they say,
oh yeah,
they just mix all the supplements and the same thing in the fat.
It's like it can be really whack nonetheless on it.
That's the good ones.
Quality.
Say Hi.
If you want 10% off on it.com/jocko strong bones would go into for your tenants.
In my experience.
Also Amazon.
So where do we get these books?
Sure.
We didn't do books today,
but we do what,
what,
66% of the time would you say you do books?
Yeah,
maybe more.
Sometimes more than one role.
I,
yeah.
Last time we did three bucks,
three bucks,
boom.
All on the website,
by the way.
Yup.
So anyway,
if you,
this is another support yourself situation.
A lot of time people ask,
Hey,
you know,
which book was that again?
You know,
and they've got to go backward and don't last for me for a reading list.
Hey,
do you have some kind of reading lists?
I'm like,
yes.
I got a reading lessons on [inaudible],
podcast.com every book that I end,
and by the way,
are there books that are,
they're good books that you've read that day you haven't put on the podcast?
Not really.
When I read a book and it's good,
it's going on the podcast.
Yeah.
If I read a book and it's lame,
it's not going on the podcast.
Now,
there's some books that are informational,
but they don't cut it for the podcast.
Yeah.
I wouldn't recommend them.
I'll tell you a little,
a little.
I just realized this.
I had a book selected for the podcast like three weeks ago and I got a hundred
pages into it.
They didn't cut the mustard for the podcast and I'll tell you though,
one of the major reasons for those of you that recommend me books a lot,
one of the major reasons that it didn't cut the mustard for the podcast is not
only was it not a first person account but it didn't even have like a lot of
excerpts of first person accounts.
It was just factually this is what happened,
this is what happened,
this is what happened is very well detailed.
It was a good book but it wasn't podcast cause if you,
if you want to do that,
if we're just going to read facts,
dates,
facts,
elements,
maneuvering,
that's that's,
you could just listen to the audio book,
right?
Yeah.
Whore or just go look on Wikipedia and it's going to tell you the dates and
times and where the units maneuvered and who won the battle and how many people
casualties.
They were,
right.
All that stuff's in there.
We don't want just that.
I want to hear what the people were thinking.
I want to hear that from the human beings.
Yup.
So even though there's people send me books,
if you're going to send me a book,
look for the first person account.
If it's not a first person account,
like machete season,
that's not a first person account,
but it,
it interviews the killers.
So you're hearing the first person accounts and man.
Yup.
And that reading list.
So that reading links reading list is pretty,
pretty well vetted.
Then like straight up,
if it doesn't pass the Jocko
approval of recommendation,
it's not going,
it's not going on the podcast not going on this topic.
And therefore consequently,
no,
I'd rather not do a podcast and put a lane book on the podcast.
It's not happening.
Boom.
And that's the standard right there.
So Jocko podcast.com top menu,
little thing says books from the podcast.
All of them.
Yup.
And what I'm kind of starting to do is like,
you know how I,
like I mentioned that book of mine is called Mind Games.
Just a small little book.
I think you put it on there.
Yeah.
Somebody,
somebody tweeted,
I didn't know you put it on there.
Yeah.
So I'll put that kind of,
if you're,
if we mentioned a cool book and let's say you,
for what,
let's say it doesn't fit or you didn't get to it or whatever,
but there's some sort of a,
for lack of a better term,
buzz going around it,
he'll put it on there.
Nonetheless.
Point there is get the books from their click through there.
That's a good way to support small actions.
Big Reaction.
And if you're just go,
we're just gonna shop for duct tape and other,
you know,
stuff that you mean to do that too?
Like feeling website it up.
Double support.
Yes.
Dang.
Still one action.
Okay.
One big reaction.
You understand what I'm saying?
Also subscribe to the podcast on Itunes,
stitcher,
Google play and other podcast providing platforms.
Oh,
that's a good way to support of course.
And also youtube.
Okay.
Put some excerpts on there when?
Yesterday.
Today.
Yeah.
Yesterday.
So those are even,
and I knew this before,
but those are getting more and more in my opinion,
significantly valuable because even I,
you know,
I don't memorize every word of every podcast,
but when I go through and I kind of look at it and you know,
and then,
you know,
I listened to it,
listen to the three minutes or whatever.
It's like a good little reminder.
It's like a refresher and that's not to mention,
let's see if I totally forgot it,
you know?
Yeah.
Like oh and not to mention if you hear it and you go,
that reminds me of bill.
He's having that issue,
going to send it over to bill,
no problem.
Shareable.
Yep.
And he's going to,
he's going to probably watch it as opposed to,
hey bill,
here's,
here's the,
the podcast I was talking about with your issue.
It's hey,
three hours and 27 minutes long.
Get Som,
you're right.
Bill might not listen to that quite yet.
And he might get around to,
it.
Might not,
not if he's in a hurry,
not if he has a busy life.
Still might find a way.
Anyway,
but there are shareable and there quicker.
So when you click on it,
you can listen to them.
They're excerpts including those and also other videos I'm gonna put on there.
But you know,
we're working on those.
So yeah,
youtube subscribe,
get some as they say.
Also,
Jack was a store.
It's called Jocko store Jocko store.com.
That's the website.
It's an online store.
It's a good one.
Just did a little revamping of it.
Little bit,
little bit more user friendly.
Not that it wasn't user friendly before,
but you know,
you can,
I don't know,
I think it's a little cleaner or whatever.
Um,
but you know,
nonetheless,
the shirts are still available there.
If you like the shirts.
He liked the designs.
Get some,
I'm not saying hey guys,
support by buying shirts.
I'm not saying that.
Not saying that at all.
I'm saying go to the website Jocko,
store.com.
Check them out if you like them.
Get them support that way.
That's how also some travel travel mugs on there.
Some bumper stickers,
this hoodies.
But should we be wearing hoodies right now?
Well we shouldn't here.
Yeah,
we live in California,
southern California.
Some people live in cold places where Alaska.
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah,
that's true.
Our Way.
Yeah,
that's true.
Also rash guards on there though.
So is it too soon to have another rash guard?
It's too soon.
Huh?
I don't really necessarily think so.
Yeah,
I actually think more rash guards is better.
Is Better.
The more the better.
Yeah.
Well Hey,
we got two out so there's,
you know,
rash guards on there as well.
Some women's stuff and um,
yeah,
if you want to support that way,
get yourself a garment.
There's a sick rash guard.
The CIC rash guard from,
like I said,
I've been hanging out a little bit with a guy named Pete Roberts from origin
gies up in Maine.
Yeah,
my home of record for the military by the way,
in New England and he made a,
he made a rash guard like a special 4th of July Day rash guard.
And I'm going to go ahead and say affirmative.
It's out of control.
You've got to check it out.
It is George Washington
wearing a [inaudible]
riding a snake,
a giant snake.
The don't tread on me snake.
So it's,
I don't know if he's gonna make a lot of them,
but if you don't have one,
I think we all should basically have fun.
Origin main.com you can get one of those.
Origin origin main m a.
I.
N.
E.
Yeah.
Origin main.com and what you know,
where you know where they're made once you guess where they're made?
Well you figure mean no,
you figure,
oh well he's,
if he's,
if he's getting a rash guard,
they're probably made in China.
Maybe.
Or maybe they're made in Pakistan maybe.
Or maybe they're made in Taiwan,
but there's also a whole bunch of places that make them like Sri Lanka and
Vietnam and Thailand.
Maybe they're made there.
You'd be wrong on every single one of those.
Cause you know where they're made America.
They're made in Maine.
Yeah.
So you met want to order one,
but do they source like the material every frank,
it's from May.
It's from America.
Pete's crazy Pete.
He doesn't play around,
especially
woven.
He's woven as an eat.
He weaves his own material for geese to make these with.
Yeah,
that's straight on me.
That's straight up.
That's this.
This made Mary,
the cotton comes from little South Carolina or something,
shipped up to Maine looms.
Do you know what to leave?
Know to Loomis fruit of the loom.
So it's like here,
here's Holly put it together ultimately.
So alumut makes,
uh,
you know we've stuff right?
Yeah.
It's a little,
it's a basically a big weaving machine.
I mean there's more to it than that.
Of course.
So now remember the brand fruit of the loom?
Yeah.
Oh,
I guess like there's fruit,
fruit of the loom.
Well,
origin actually has their own looms once again here in Maine in your hometown
layers,
bro.
Anyways,
check those out.
Yeah.
Then you'll,
you'll be to say you'll be fired up.
I'm going gonna go ahead and say you will be inspired.
And it's funny too because the,
uh,
the rash guard design,
the American 4th of July rash guard design,
it's,
you know,
things can get so over the top that they actually become cool.
Yeah.
I think that's where it's at.
That's where it's at.
And like me,
I'm all about the subtle designs.
Right.
You know,
what should we do?
Make it black and then don't put much on it.
That to me,
he was took the other direction.
I'm going to have a giant snake.
I'm going to have George Washington with a black belt on.
It ain't an origin.
Gee,
I'm going to have,
you know,
that's what I'm talking about America.
That's kind of like uncle.
Why when you go to the north shore and you can go north,
north,
north or you can go west,
west,
west and you go too far.
Cause quite,
it's like a circle.
Before you know it,
you're essentially at the same place.
Well,
yeah,
yeah.
I see.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
At first I wasn't following you.
Yes you do get to the same place.
He went to crazy.
He went to Korea.
But he went so far in the world in the realm of crazy that it became dope.
You know,
cause you have like we,
we consider dope.
It's like the perfect mix of breezy and understated and current contemporary or
rebellion against.
Yeah.
But he went in that one direction that you don't really go for mass acceptance.
And then he took it too far and now it's right into the right where it needs to
be.
Dope
dopeness go.
Psychological warfare.
Hey,
here's a question.
Tough question.
Psychological warfare is this false motivation?
Wait,
wait,
let me explain what it is.
So psychological warfare is an album with tracks of Jocko sane basically,
you know,
in moments of weakness on your journey,
whatever,
waking up early,
sticking to the Diet,
you know,
trying to get stuff done,
anti procrastination stuff.
You can play these tracks and Jack will tell you how to get over that weakness
for that moment.
So the question is,
is that false motivation,
cause you did mention that you can use the false motivation.
Yeah.
Well maybe you are at that point,
right?
It is possible.
You just can't depend on it.
You can't be like,
hey this,
this is my little thing.
Yeah,
that's a good point.
It's going to get you there.
But if you're not disciplined yourself,
those tracks are going to do anything for you,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
So keep these mice,
they are pretty good.
They're pretty powerful that it was like a,
I say,
and I know we got
make psychological warfare to uh,
I,
I've,
I've gotta continue gather a couple more tracks that I'm thinking about and what
people been asking for so that they can,
you know,
have a little,
we'll spot if they need it.
Spot psychologically spot.
Yeah.
So just,
you know what I was thinking of naming spike psychological warfare to what?
Psychological warfare,
too
advanced events,
but yeah,
that is what it is.
It's a spot.
So just like false motivation that can be just like a spot.
Like you can't roll into the gym with your workout partner and be like,
Hey,
I'm going to get under this bench is four or five on there.
I want you to do the whole thing.
I want you to upright row.
Yeah.
That Ale,
you know?
Yeah.
You don't,
that's not what a spot for us,
not what any of these things for it's,
I'm going to do this in the unlikely event that I run into something that may
cause me to fail.
You got me that rest of the way.
That's it.
That's what psychological warfare.
He's too by the way.
But in my experience and opinion,
you can lean on that pretty heavily.
It'll get you through.
It's my opinion also Jocko white tea on Amazon.
You can get that there.
And I guess I got asked on Twitter if I ever used any performance enhancing
drugs,
you know,
and I said no.
But honestly,
let's just go ahead and face it.
I'm white tea is kind of the King of performance enhancement as far as I've
seen.
So obviously it's the only substance on the market that is guaranteed to add
7,554 pounds to your deadlift.
So does that performance enhancing?
Luckily it's not being tested for right now.
You know by the U S D s a s p Usada.
Yeah,
them.
So right now you can get it.
Yeah,
get it.
You can just get that massive increase in everything that you do.
That's cool.
Also weigh the warrior kid and me and so many people have been posting pictures
of kids doing pull ups and kids pulling tires and kids studying flashcards and
kids making their own warrior a kid and memorizing the presidents and it's
honestly,
it's awesome to see kids in their first Jiu Jitsu class.
It's so good to see.
So thanks everyone that is posted that and and showing what's going on and
spreading the word.
Thank you for doing that.
And if you really actually want to support this podcast,
don't worry about the podcast,
don't support the podcast,
don't worry about it.
Go buy this book for some kids that you know because the feedback is just,
it's awesome.
It's awesome to see and I can see that is absolutely impacting kids and I just
couldn't be happier about that.
And if you want to help,
don't worry about me.
Don't worry about echo.
Charles gets get this book for some kids,
it's the book we should have had when we were kids.
Get kids on the right path.
I guess if you really want a sport,
you could,
you could get it through Amazon,
right through then you'd be good.
Do Devil gravitational.
Also,
discipline equals freedom field manual.
So many questions that I get asked or answered in the book beyond what I,
you know,
workouts,
food,
sleep
plus.
It's also contains the core of my belief system.
What keeps me going,
how I overcome setbacks,
everything.
It's all in there,
and I'll tell you,
it's not a normal book.
This is not normal.
This is not a normal book in any stretch.
My publisher says he's never seen him to book anything close to this.
It's outside the box of anything.
I've never seen anything like it.
We're going out on a little limb here.
It's sorta like the podcast because there's not too many pockets.
There's no podcast that's doing what we're doing is,
I don't know why I haven't heard one.
Not that I know of.
I haven't heard one.
You know what I mean?
So it's sort of like that.
We're entering the same zone in my opinion.
There's words there,
there's pages there.
Yes,
like normal books.
There's patterns there.
There's layers there and it comes out October 17th so ordered up.
You can get that first batch.
You weren't the one that says first edition,
right?
Sure.
It's the one you want on the inside cover on.
It says first printing.
That's the one.
And also,
you know,
get,
you know your friend that's off the path,
you know?
Yes.
Your friend.
Oh,
you grew up with this front and they're off the path one for them.
It's not normal.
Not a normal book.
The one that needs discipline.
Get them this book.
Also of course,
extreme ownership,
combat leadership lessons from the battlefield to use in your business and your
life.
Wherever you're leading,
whoever you're leading.
Extreme ownership,
you can pick that one up.
Also,
echelon front
leadership and management consulting me,
Leif Babin,
JP Denelle,
Dave Burke.
Yeah.
You want to get your leadership team unified.
Okay.
Email info@echelonfront.com will come and make it happen.
And finally the muster.
Okay.
The first semester that we did in San Diego sold out.
The one we did in New York sold out.
But when we're doing an Austin sold out.
So if you wanted to come to those and you didn't make it,
sorry,
you know,
but we are back in San Diego September 14th and 15th back at the Omni hotel down
town.
Muster zero zero for new material by the way.
New Material but same attitude,
same passion.
We're going to bring it,
we're going to burn it down.
We will see you there and until we do see you there,
we'll see you on the interwebs on Twitter,
Instagram and Dash Facebooky Baja
Echo is at echocharles and I am at Jocko Willink.
Can't thanks once again for listening to those in uniform,
especially those overseas.
Thank you for being strong and brave and standing up for what you and we believe
in.
Yeah.
And also thanks to police,
law enforcement,
firefighters,
paramedics and other first responders.
Thanks for keeping us safe here at home and to everyone else out there.
Okay.
Like First Lieutenant Leonard Isaac asked,
see how you can help people.
Ask how you can help them and clean up what's around you.
It never run away from something you're afraid of.
Okay.
And as Doctor Horror Cova told us,
whether you're at an operating table or a leaf,
or a sewing machine,
or on a construction side,
or your child's cradle or wherever you're working,
do your work skillfully,
honestly,
and happily,
and with your whole being.
Yeah.
Do your best in everything you do.
And as they both taught us,
remember
our time here is short.
So get out there and live,
and until next time,
this is echo and Jocko out.
Okay.